hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to jurassic world
evolution we're going to play this and
we're going to get some dinos and
they're probably going to kill everybody
on the island
and then jeff jeff boldbloom is going to
talk
my name is dr ian malcolm you may have
heard of me uh-huh
well correction you should have heard it
right you go much actually now that
you're here
so before you are the islands that you
need to manage
if you the can deaths
geez if only if only there had been
five what kind of name for island is
five deaths
i'm cabot finch public relations and
crisis management
and i'm here to help you you'll start by
building a hammond creation lab
we're good okay what's a hammond
creation lab
we've already started on an enclosure
for you you should just attach it to the
side
but watch out for dinosaurs uh-huh ah
just kidding
yeah my whole family was murdered by
dinosaurs
ooh something tells me i probably
shouldn't blast it right in the middle
of the fence there
but you know what i like living on the
edge
let's do right there
focus on what you're here to do which is
create dinosaur facilities on the
islands we call
the five deaths actually la cinco
muertes because spanish is the lingo of
choice around here
of course it is all right
you'll need to connect it to the
pre-existing network of paths and the
power grid
okay oh
okay all right i did i did it test
incubating a dinosaur oh boy we'll start
with a struthus
i know what that is the creation lab and
pick a hatchery bay
there's enough genome data for your
first viable dinosaur
do i have to sit on it myself oh boy
i like him oh yeah that's a good
struthio mymus
i'ma call you struthi or mimo i'm gonna
call you
mimu they're gonna be meemu all right
modified genome can i do that can i do
that
can i just start picking random pieces
in and out of this attack
why do we need attack and defense stats
that's what i'm kind of curious about
all right whatever you know it's
probably fine
um applied ooh
apply gene okay v ability is low oh i
like low vietnam
gene what the hell let's put bat dna in
here
that's probably pretty good lifespan
goes up that's nice i always like a long
life
yeah okay let's do that yeah let's um
let's do
that yeah i like that a nice whatever
wait what is oh
oh that's what that is okay apply
and then i didn't apply the bat let's
apply the bat
okay that's probably good just mix and
match that's like a potluck dinner but
with jeans
all right incubate all right i got warm
butts
of the ambitious undoing extinction
playing with nature's laws
what can possibly go wrong come on
doctor
you know we've learned so much and
invested even more
in our jurassic operations since the
last time
yes mr finch yes the the last time
there's always a last time and a next
okay you're being real pessimistic about
that
jeff goldblummer why are you doing that
okay ready for release
go be free go
have fun oh memu
it begins the most precious moment oh he
was a result of
incalculable actions and reactions
trials and errors
genetic mutations unknowable
combinations
chaos all leading to a living
breathing thinking being an entity
distinct and unique and now we
you just manufacture them
so well done i guess
thank you i'm proud of what i've done
jesus jeff goldblum he's so mad
why is he so mad just cause a few
thousand people died the dinos
is that really is that really that bad
probably
all right anyway okay mimu let me get a
good look at you
oh you're so cute okay where are you
where are you going all right mimu
you're doing great
i'd like jeff goldblum like
pessimistically nagging me for every
little mistake that i do
what kind of stats have you got great
stats oh
drinking sun actually okay all right
good goodbye i guess did i do good
did i did i do good what is this are you
just leaving me on my own now
the hammond foundation has three main
areas of interest
security entertainment and science
why did you say they've already nudged
the heads of each division to reach out
to you personally
they'll offer opportunities and
incentives for you to be part of their
team
choose one of their contracts it'll help
you develop your facility
why did you say security list security
something tells me security is probably
the most important but i
i as a youtuber i am all about that
entertainment
oh hell yeah i'm isaac hey i've been
hearing good things about you
i'm in charge of the entertainment
division here what good is the world's
greatest show if no one sees it
don't answer that's rhetorical and
painfully obvious
what i'm saying is that we need people
in our parks
fill up our facilities with warm bodies
numbers bring revenue
excitement and opportunities warm
juicy bodies mmm filled to the brim with
meat with those warm
delicious delicious bodies
oh we're going to fill this bar
requested from the division heads
inside the control room complete these
to increase your reputation
and gain additional revenue to keep
expanding your park
ah okay all right ben i'll do exactly
that
i'll do exactly what you're saying
actually i didn't hear a word what
you're saying
it all went straight over my head i was
just thinking about those
juicy delicious
bodies expedition center ah let's try
right there oh yeah so
one more thing your reputation your rep
quote unquote keep an eye on it okay
if you have a solid reputation with a
division you're more likely to benefit
from them
financially i mean but like life
it's a balancing act each division is
vying for your attention
and if they don't get it they tend to
take it personally
wow okay all right this is a business i
don't take
anything personally in the business it's
all about the finances and the numbers
that's all we got to worry about
if we don't have the finances and the
numbers nothing's going to work out for
any of us entertainment division is
taking notice of your success
as your reputation increases with them
so too
does the opportunity to tackle more
challenging missions
ah let's do this how uh
how do i do oh who's
uh oh okay hey it's isaac
hey i got some cool stuff you need to be
a part of so i'm putting it out there
come on and help the winning team mine
oh my
god i i will i absolutely will i want to
be part of a winning i'm a winner
i've always told myself i'm a winner my
mom always
always have told me that i i am a
straight-up winner
oh okay there we go i'm staring at it
like how do i do this
start i'm ready i'll come on now
you know you won't give me that money is
this where people come in
i am all about the show me too these
dinosaurs
we have one unlike any other on the
planet
theme parks rely on drawing people in
and what is more attractive
than new dinosaurs well me of course
yeah no what i'm saying is let's get
some fresh dinos
in the hopper dinos in the hopper like a
paintball gun we're going to
shoot dinos at people because that
sounds
[ __ ] awesome i would love to do that
can we get a giant dino gun that just
really just like their mouths open to
scoop up as many
warm bodies as possible oh yeah
i think we're all the fossil center lets
you extract dna from
fossils and amber in order to create new
dinosaur genomes wow
exciting yeah that actually is exciting
viable genomes allow you to create
dinosaurs at the ham and creation lab
expeditions sometimes bring back extra
fines that can be sold for cash i like
cash
i like cash um view fossils
we got struthio should we actually make
the strutio better
[Music]
i think that's what we need do let's
extract that bad boy
oh yeah hmm what about this one probably
yeah i mean shouldn't we extract all
these i
i mean selling them would be great but
i'm going to entertain people i want to
get all of these
i want to get them in a big box we're
going to create like an mma cage we're
going to put all the dinos in there and
they're just going to duke it out as
hard as they can
expedition map
[Music]
what an expedition center will allow you
to send dig
teams around the world fossils dna can
be extracted from these fossils
which our scientists can then turn into
living breathing dinosaurs
and that's our true lifeblood
okay thank you i was already in the
middle of that i was doing just fine
we're gonna get the carnivorous ones
your first
expedition team is out thank you they'll
bring back what they find to the fossil
center for extraction
thank you thank you thank you for
noticing how hard i work
okay so we've almost got the genome that
we need job is simple really
create dinosaurs which attract visitors
to your facilities
brings in capital money huh
you can do more research to build better
facilities and create
more dinosaurs there we go a circle of
life
development and resources nature and
commerce
see simple money
you gotta get some money get the capital
so you can make the money wink wink warm
bodies
i get it i understand we're on the same
page okay so i didn't get enough i got
to get one more
but when my expedition comes back then
i'm going to be able to do what we need
to do but let's see what we got here
the research center lets you improve
your park in various exciting ways
new buildings upgrades and more await
okay that's all you're gonna say about
it okay all right whatever like i give a
[ __ ] about upgrades
all right how does this help me
entertaining give me an upgrade that
allows a t-rex to try to juggle with its
tiny arms because that sounds hilarious
i want to see a t-rex trying its bed
like i can't do it and then it's a lean
all the way down to pick it up when it
drops them that sounds
hilarious intuitive learning
that'll help it juggle hell yeah
intuitive learning that seems obvious
did they come back yet they got to be
close right
yes maybe yes you should extract
genomes from fossils dude i'm already on
it inside your fossil center dude shut
your hole
increase the amount of viable data you
have to create dinosaurs wow look at
that's very high quality oh we're going
to extract that dna we're going to get
ourselves a t-rex
mmm we're all um
all right let's see we need small power
station okay
i'm owen grady oh hi to my friends i've
seen things i'd rather not talk about
but it hasn't dampened my commitment to
the dinosaurs
the raptors more generally and me and
blue specifically
we have a special relationship like what
i have with claire
less complicated anyway nice to meet you
who the [ __ ] are you power is something
we simply cannot ignore when it comes to
our operations
without power we uh well we we don't
have any power
who that who the [ __ ] was that
who was that that wasn't chris
that was what they got jeff goldblum to
voices but they didn't get chris
that was awful that was horrible that
felt wrong i feel dirty
no no no so i've uh i've already heard
that putting uh putting a t-rex
in the same enclosure as uh my other
dinosaur is a bad idea right okay all
right
ever i know that's a bad idea okay we
don't have any gene there what's worse
treating these creatures like grist for
the mill or propping them up is
curiosities
i don't know what grist is but you know
that's all right robust digestion really
gonna need a robust digestion when you
uh
meet up with meemu there eh all right
this seems pretty good i don't think we
have any more that we could do so we've
applied that
all right now let's incubate this bad
boy
right up
[Laughter]
a horrible horrific massacre
in the middle of my park that's where i
need to build observation decks
that's what i need all right i need to
send people on an expedition
all right um oh yeah oh we're gonna need
more
ceratosaurus dna
for those warm bodies
and you'll learn once he's learning to
juggle then he'll have an ambition for
us he'll get a taste
for learning where is he oh he's not
done yet
well i'm an impatient son of a [ __ ] you
need to hurry up with what you're doing
okay genetic research
let's try medical treatment what do we
got hook worm parasite
oh no they can get a oh no um
they can get sick well i don't want my
guy to get sick
i want him to be healthy 100 healthy
unstoppable even that's like my ideal
for my dinosaurs i want them to be
completely
irresponsibly healthy
oh boy oh boy
here you go why are they looking down
they should be looking up
yeah yeah no hook worms for you
oh yeah very scary i like your horn
is what we strive to maintain here on
the islands we do that
by making sure their needs are met in a
way it's kind of like taking care of the
dinos
right more demands and less
understanding
am i right oh yeah there we go oh
oh he's on to something oh meemo
run mimi run mimu now
oh oh um
uh oh oh boy
remo run oh no well that was that did
not last
[Laughter]
long feel horrible
oh no then now we reach the inevitable
life begets death but here's the
question that you got to ask yourself
was this avoidable the answer
of course not death it's always coming
but could you have delayed it well
that's maybe another story ah could i
have delayed it um
probably not uh the only thing i know is
how to accelerate the process
all right now i just need to send some
humans in to go collect the corpse oh
it's gone
all right never mind then well this guy
i don't know what his name
jerry jerry is fed jerry has been fed
and uh you know we're all happier for it
hey
come back jerry jerry where'd you this
is lambert
head of security yours theirs
and mine welcome to the islands so
here's our basic conundrum
we want to keep our animals under
control while simultaneously encouraging
instinctive behaviors
because these animals have potential as
combatants
everyone's fair object myself included
is to have these animals running free
and loose in the park
but we can't exploit them globally
without taking some chances
hmm okay
i like i like the combatant thing you
were saying there
that sounds real cool how do i make them
fight because that that sounds real cool
all right construct and power a fast
food restaurant
i've already got one i've already got
one here the park
this this little enclosure this very
fast food it's running
as fast as it can like for its life
but it's just not fast enough is what
you're saying okay so i got to get
faster
food i want i want a nice restaurant
overlooking uh the
the the death zone here i think this is
like
this is this is gonna be okay emergency
shelter
why why would we need that nothing's
going to go wrong gift shop
fat oh fast fud oh it's too big build it
in
[Laughter]
problem solved i don't see an issue with
uh anything that's happening oh here's a
door right here
okay well let's just let's just plop
around that yep
oh yeah that looks that looks real
i don't see an issue well i don't think
unless you guys see an issue which
i don't think any oh well that's
i already knew about this dead dinosaur
should be removed with a transport team
to prevent disease oh
well i guess there's no corpse because
it was eaten so
um oh well all right let's get power
let's get power going from here to
right there that's looking good
now now we're gonna have some power why
is there no power
oh do i need a substitution okay instead
of uh wait no let's let's how do i
how do i bolt there we go bulldoze that
let's get rid of that
let's put a substitution that's not a
substitution
there we go okay this is good all right
put the oh snap that bad boy right in
there they really
they really know what they're doing here
all right so we gotta build a road
let's see we build a road from here oh
build cost obstructed well we're just
gonna have to get it out of the way now
aren't we
okay we don't need demolishk one yeah
yeah there we go okay this is probably
fine
all right we'll put this right there oh
a nice
curve to it that's what that's what we
all really like
now people can eat and see look he's
friend
he's coming well he's so curious he's
like what's this
um oh this looks fun all righty then
[Music]
hum diddly dum dee humble dum deeb
diddy dee doo hmm
dinosaur threat he's threatened who's
threatening my dinosaur
oh come on now oh he's running he's
scared
oh oh no come back oh
someone pushed him out of his home i
can't believe this
i can't oh he's so scared somebody go up
and give him a big old hug
[Music]
see look if you just try to understand
them
if you just try to understand them then
they're not so bad we're not so
different after all
look entertainment objective look at
that
he's beautiful where are you going oh
look see
he's just he's hot he's looking for some
shade
what a beautiful beautiful creature hey
look at that research item from research
center
oh i am making money i am
making a profit oh hell yeah
all right hang on i gotta go i gotta
research something control room
research building that one
got it people want to get clothes i mean
their clothes are going to get real
bloody
so you know they want to they want to
definitely have that where are you going
you little scamp
hum dooley ho ho hilah are you going for
a jog
yeah exercise is very important see look
at them they're going to the fast food
restaurant they're totally fine
oh what's wrong what's wrong buddy you
lonely you do you want a friend
oh i can get you a friend i'll get you a
friend don't you worry i'll
i'll get you a friend i know it's real
lonely looking
good around here huh i love what you're
doing with the place
[Laughter]
things are looking good around here keep
it up champ slogger
oh man you are really really
really doing great oh boy
all right he's already got it a friend's
already on the way see he's not causing
nobody no trouble
see that's the thing this guy's causing
he he's full it's the thing so he's not
you know he's not he's very comfortable
look how comfortable he is look at that
comfort that's so nice
ah let's see oh we got more fossils yes
we do
let's go research those um well we
already got em
i mean i might as well i'm gonna be
making money hand over fist anyway ooh
silver all right sure fine by me
let's go send another expedition anybody
else
let's see hwang yangosaurus
all right sure i don't know what that
means but let's go up to the huang gang
how long until our uh friend is ready oh
it's gonna be a while okay so we need
to research something
uh intensive repair okay that's probably
pretty good
i should probably get like them a forest
camo
so that they can't be seen when they're
like in the trees because
maybe he's good enough because i don't
know where he is i mean he's probably
fine but
that's probably fine okay so he's off
doing his own thing he's having fun over
there
i will get oh see no danger no danger no
more
i don't know where he went but oh where
is he
oh come on now oh over there okay
dolly's having a good time okay all
right so
we need to build a
clothes shop oh hell yeah
people are always gonna be wanting to
buy clothes once they're uh you know
after they piss their pants from the the
dinosaurs not that there's any actual
danger but you know people probably
probably be a little surprised at least
it's like a jump scare
that eats you you know really like the
original jump scare was when
a tiger would just roar from out of the
out of the out of the forest like you
you would be like oh
that would whoa you got me and then he
gets you
you know that that was really the
original jump scare and i think people
forget that
hell yeah research did we get more
fossils
nice i don't know what a huang is i
don't know what that is but i
like it huang cione dat
no dinosaur dna okay rhenium
whatever that is all right we're good
it's time for friend
release oh my goodness
look at you you are gonna get along
so well i can't even imagine
i can't even imagine it i'm out of money
that's impossible
that's impossible that's absolutely
unpossible
if you think i'm out of money you're
just out of your mind so don't even
don't even try that
this time a ceratosaurus
spines that run down its back ah bladed
horn on its head
oh just what you don't want to run into
when you're out there alone
or in a group alone or in a group you
just don't want to run into them
he's curious don't fall over
what are you doing no come on man he's
just blair uh oh
my god oh my god
bad bad sarah michael sarah
that's bad that's real bad
you're bad uh oh alone or in a group
that's no crunching the guests
that's a bad that's bad
that's real bad are you gonna behave
yourself
you're gonna be you take a drink you
think about what you've done
that's enough crunching for one day okay
and shockingly no one is stopping me
oh oh oh i fell over again they always
fall over
oh no oh
my god hmm well
no one seems to be upset about this turn
of events
jeremy jimmy j what is this whatever
your name was
jj now now
what have we talked about crunching the
guests
huh can't believe man more people
there's so many people here
uh i guess what i'm doing is working
people want that real exciting
experience
people all just want to like really sink
their teeth into this they want to like
latch on
none they wanted to feel they want to
feel they want to feel something real
people will pay for those experiences
so um yeah it's pretty good all right
operations
ranger station oh resupply feeders okay
they need to resupply the feeders okay
that's probably important
there that's pretty good how is that not
connected by itself
you'd think that would be connected by
itself all right there we go
ah dr dua this is our new director of
operations hello i'm aware cabot
i'm dr dua i run the science division of
our operation
okay you're going to need to build your
reputation in the science division
not easy with me around but your manage
that means
managing our dinosaur population and
seeing that they are flourishing
no i'm okay all right no i'm good thank
you no need for that i'm already
well taken care of we've got
so much cool stuff happening here and we
do not need
anything from you i am out of money
what did i need to build a viewing
gallery where even is a viewing gallery
you can get
ah i can build it i can still build it
oh they're gonna get such a good view
oh man oh that's so good oh view
away we see see look michael sarah's
still in here
can i name them can i do that all right
you're michael might
looks like you've run out of power sarah
i don't know if i spelled that right
build more power stations
or increase your output oh increase so i
can just like overload this thing can i
just like blast it up
like really just slam it out there can i
just like
can i just like tell them to go harder
well i can't build one so what do you
expect me to do
how about a power upgrade i don't i
don't have enough money
where's my missions which where's
where's my missions
i thought i was i had a million dollar
contract i'm making super money but
what the hell man these guys they expect
so much out of me but i can only do so
much okay we're gonna get an observation
deck i like what i'm seeing
let's keep it up satisfaction is what we
aim to give our guests
make them appreciate the little things
yeah and the big things with the teeth
and
glassy eyes that could swallow them
whole yeah appreciate those things
preach them preach those things we're
gonna preach them hard oh they are
preaching
oh you better believe that here in this
place
we preach everything that we got one
thing has no power but that's okay it's
only the ranger station we didn't need
that anyway
all right so weenie
[Music]
construct live bait feeder oh i like
live bait how do i
how do i do that then the guests is it
in the guest section i'm guessing it
just like picks a guest up by a crane
and just drops them right in is that
what it is
live bait fee oh it's just
too expensive why is everything in this
game so expensive
man maybe there's another dinosaur park
that wants to buy michael sarah good
dinosaur right his
authenticity's like wow combat infamy
oh can i actually make fighting bits can
i actually honestly make fighting pits
for my dinosaurs
oh yes oh yes so i'm making a profit i
guess i just gotta wait until i get a
hundred thou
but man oh come on
there we go contract oh request a new
contract
give me a new contract entertain hey
just heard of a great opportunity we
should get behind
okay can i have a hundred thousand what
is the contract
build connect and power a hotel oh
smart oh no no michael michael
michael michael
what the hell we're gonna get a hotel
eventually once we get this live bait
feeder we are going to be so
so good am i still making money yeah
yeah i am guest injury lawsuits oh
that's not so bad
but we can we can manage with that oh no
wait no we can't manage with that
oh hmm well
huh something seems something about my
business model doesn't seem right
hmm maybe you guys a lot of look behind
you hey you ever thought about turning
around uh you ever thought about
i'm sorry that's that's so that i
shouldn't uh oh your park is bankrupt
you'll need to raise cash with what you
have sell unnecessary buildings fossils
dinosaurs
oh i can sell a dinosaur how do i do
that how do i sell a dino
how do i sell a dino can i sell a dino
you're you were jeremy you're jeremy how
do i
sell jeremy no
jared god damn it jeremy all right these
guys they were they were behaving well
and and i i think like it's
i think it's video games violent video
games are really influencing
these dinosaurs they're really causing
them to come like out of control
they like you play one violent video
game and the next thing you know
eating up people crunching on left and
right kron's crunch crunch can't do it
yeah i can't sell one i i uh
yeah it's impossible to sell hmm well
well
oh the ranger station how do we sell
that
wait what if i just click the demolish
button
oh there we go oh wait we're still not
enough debt
hmm all right well the one thing we
don't need is power
well maybe we do we need to power that
i've got a bolt someone's gonna come up
to
to michael sarah over here with a
bulldozer and just be like
i'm taking you down nope it don't oh
well the roads
if i sell the roads we don't need roads
obviously
duh i should have realized i'm so smart
all right we got this no roads no roads
it's more natural this way anyway
we're building trees too so that's just
like double extra plus
all right no no no no no no
nope nope nope nope none of this none of
this
oh yeah oh let's get that money back all
right none of this
none of this none of this no more
clothes we don't need clothes
and we've got money we've got money all
right
so we just need to power a hotel let's
demolish this let's small as this
smallest of this let's demolish this and
let's build a hotel
that seems pretty good to me live bait
feeder
right this is the only exhibit that we
really need right
there that's real nice and then we're
gonna build a
hotel ah there we go
oh that's looking pretty
[Music]
bam
million dollars yeah
million dollars start running at maximum
happiness
and our guest numbers are up as a result
that's what makes the entertainment
division
the envy of the rest we get the results
am i right oh my god you are so right
our scientific research improves
of course i'd never tell this to isaac
directly heard it
i was going to add no
nope no no no too late heard it
later doc
[Laughter]
mission complete maximum happiness
people are so so happy people are so
unbelievably happy oh wait what our goat
a goat um goat
all right jeremy you can crunch the goat
if you want i guess
the goat jeremy come on now jeremy
jerry look behind you maybe oh no
but i was looking at the hotel no i had
a suite
with a view reserved now can i get my
deposit back
are they gonna fight well this is
they're meeting for the first time
it's a beautiful thing they're meeting
they're meeting
they're meeting for the first time wait
jeremy no
michael sarah wants to say hi three
words
contract you yes
contract me no all right i'm good give
me a million dollars or give me nothing
because i don't even want to be
bothered with that oh man all right
yeah we are doing so fresh and fun
i'm not saying i could have done it
better myself but i probably could have
but i'm not saying as i said i think
anyway nice job yeah nice job thank you
thank you so much all right so we need
to make this
this place poppin need to make this
place popping we need a gift
shop ooh three stars of fun on that one
that that is a lot of fun we're gonna
get this gift shop going
we got this all right we're gonna have a
restaurant right by the live bait feeder
so it's like
michael sarah or jeremy have like a
choice all right let's see
obstructed by nothing all right this is
good
oh yeah that's good this is how we're
gonna make our money back anyway so and
then
uh let's put a close shop back
up we got rid of it for a little bit but
it is coming back by popular demand
and we are good to go oh hell yeah
all right we're making a profit
we're actually making a no we're not
okay never mind we're
we are not i thought we were
but we're not so you kind of lied to me
just saying this you kind of lied to me
and that's really rude
i don't like that but whatever oh look
they went back in the enclosure oh
that's world
wait i want to see if jeremy goes back
in there and then i'm going to see if i
can build a fence
get in come on jeremy come on oh wait
was that michael or is that jeremy
oh come on yes yes yes
oh no okay we'll just do a fence we
don't need to get in there anyway
oh problem solved
problem solved now the dinos have a
steady food supply
and uh they're back in the enclosure
which i think now that i look back on it
i probably should
this is horrible this horrible i
shouldn't be laughing about this
something's so
funny
this is something so funny like i know
it's horrible but this is where they go
[Music]
[Applause]
what does this say about me as a person
what does this say about me
anyway all right we're running out of
money ah but i just solved the problem
guys come on ah you're acting like i'm
the bad guy here uh do we gotta get rid
of our hotel
oh man but okay
man all right we're getting real hotel
we need the money we need the money and
i know i'm about that
money we need an expedition place
that's expedition center that's really
where the money was
right nose the fossil center knows the
expedition and the fossil center
right oh is he breaking out what the
hell
michael sarah you okay oh no michael oh
he's fine
michael be careful be careful i wouldn't
want anything to happen
oh oh they're very huddled oh no they're
huddled in fear oh oh
no oh oh they're he's just trampling him
[Music]
maybe you guys should turn around
something bad's happening here
guys have you uh have you noticed the um
oh well i guess he's gonna poop on him
all right well
is this how the movie this is how the
movie went
so hey look these guys are having a
great time hey these guys are having the
time
we got a gift shop we got uh us fast
food and we got a clothes we got
everything we need
i don't know i thought i'd be bankrupt
by now i don't know why i'm not
i honestly i have no idea why i'm not
i'm trying to think of how to
to screw this up more and i can't think
of anything wait hang on maybe i can
give
oh wait there's only two where'd the
rest of them go i was gonna give them a
way out but uh apparently they're all
gone
so look eventually at some point at some
point the lawsuits are gonna end
and i'm gonna start making money again
ah
i want another contract give me give me
give give to me i'm bringing this
contract to you while it's still hot
well i can't exactly make an herbivore
right now anyway
[Music]
i thought i would have been bankrupt i
don't know how to sell a dinosaur
that's the problem i want to sell this
dinosaur
i want to sell but i i how do i sell
a dinosaur how do i sell a dot do i have
to google this
oh i got a tranquil
you mean i can't just tell them when
they're awake
i can't just
you mean someone can't come up with a
u-haul
and just load her in
and sell it
what is this world coming to this
is this is garbage i won't
stand for this if say i thought this
was america did the goat still
i'm sorry i thought this was america
i thought that we could buy
and sell dinosaur whenever we want i
thought this was
america i am i am i'm outraged
can't believe this i can't i can't drink
it because i don't have
the center to drink
i sold the center to drink it
so i can't exactly sell it so
all right uh oh my god is there a
possibility of making money
lawsuits are going down
there's every possibility i could bring
this back give me 30 minutes and
we're gonna we're gonna be
we're gonna be doing good oh there's two
guys left let me see
i can't well i can't break the fence
because i can't build another fence but
they seem to be well hidden i don't
think these guys know they're there so
michael sarah and jeremy are doing real
good
if only i could move the live bait
feeder in there but
alas it's uh not nor restart
restart you want me to restart this
but i but i've made so much progress
why you want are you oh really oh
yeah how bankrupt do i need to be to
lose like honestly how bankrupt would i
need to be
is there is there a lose scenario in
this game there's
no loss scenario in this game i can't
believe that
how is there no lost scenario in this
game
all right okay all right let's restart
island all right let's do this i
i would dick around more but i ran out
of things to dick around with
my next thing my next thing i'm going to
do is i'm going to build a fighting pit
i want a fighting pit oh they're going
to talk to me again
oh my god don't shut up oh my god
oh god shut up shut up
shut up oh my god i have to do the
tutorial again
this is worse than waiting oh my god i
want to die i want to die i want to die
i want to die i want to die
just kill me i want to die
all right we got this okay boom boom
baby
start with a struthus no i won't select
the creation
wait it remembers my genome progress
your first viable dinosaur
you remember it remembers it remembers
my genome progress
it remembers it remembers bird
bird build incubate we're back in
business baby
we're back in business oh let's build
two we gotta get two we gotta get two
you know we gotta get two is it still
bird dna still birds
still birds i bet it's still bird it's
still birds all right we got this birds
all the way baby
bring out the birds oh we got this oh
hell yeah ooh that one's going fast
oh hell yeah yeah
yeah oh release it release it to the
world
release it release yeah
jeremy's back jeremy's back baby
oh hell yeah michael sarah is on the way
jeremy is
back oh hell yeah all right so what i
got what up my problem was i wasn't
doing it as intelligently as i could
now i've got a second chance all right
this is not so bad
not so bad we got a chance
all right jeremy you're gonna be named
oh four
and a two stars that's what jeremy's at
all right let's go send people on
expeditions
i can't be oh wait no i have to incubate
it well
you it says i have to incubate
astruthiomimus it says i have to
you you guys saw it it says i have to i
have to
do a spruthio mias we're gonna have
lizard intensive repair it'll be able to
be eaten over and over and over again
it says i have to so i'm gonna do it go
be free
for a little bit be free be free run run
while you can
life oh precious sweet life
oh boy i'm gonna name you your memu
this is me moo's back baby mimu's back
mimi wants a fresh drink of water don't
you mean you
uh-huh okay uh we're going back to isaac
baby because
isaac knows what's up dead dinosaur oh
no what happened
tracks can be requested crunch crunch
crunch oh jeremy never change jeremy
never change
all right research center hi
hey it's isaac how you doing i got some
cool stuff you need to be a part of so
i'm putting it out there
that's three million that's three
million and you know who's about to be
born
yes it's a free million no wait no
yes look i am all about the show
these dinosaurs we have one unlike
anything
ah there we go we've got our dinos
oh they're back is what we strive to
maintain here on the island we do we do
strive for that by making sure their
needs are met
oh hell yeah in a way it's kind of like
taking care of the dinos
just with more demands and less
understanding am i right yeah
you are right you are right my friend
those guests are so demanding oh don't
eat meat
whatever no one wants to hear it loser
anyway
yeah okay all right let's put this down
i guess people can be
a little bit well fed everyone's got to
be well fed here the dinos everything we
are
oh wasn't i wait what about that
contract that i just accepted wait
no but my contract i just no i had a but
you
but you said you i was going to get a
million
you you said but you said i was but
that's not the
you you said i was supposed to get the
the the the the
did i get a million from that all right
i need clothes shop and a viewing
gallery all right we need a viewing
gallery that's what i originally
that's what i originally wanted i want i
want to put the the viewing gallery
right here and then the live feeder is
going to be like
right actually no we'll have the viewing
gallery over here
and then the live feeder will be right
in the way i want to see him like run
for it that'd be great all right so we
got that that's being built we're going
to build a clothes shop
and then these guests are going to be
safe and happy whatever
ah it's raining sell umbrellas i gotta
sell umbrellas
charge 20 for the umbrella what i'm
seeing i do too
give our guests initiate the little
things oh the little things like this
little
goat okay we're gonna have a live bait
feeder right on top of this hill
it's gonna be like it's gonna be like
feeding hill or maybe like
right here oh we gail they really want
to see that goat there
right there oh yeah they oh that
couldn't be better
that couldn't be better oh yeah they're
oh they're so happy
oh they're so happy oh they're so happy
i'm happy they're happy
we're all happy we're so happy all right
go again
wow
million dollars a million a million
look at them look at them all
look at them look at them all my guests
are so happy
i am the best i'm so good
i'm so good at what i do we're doing
great oh
triceratops that sounds like a friend of
the
jeremy and michael cera are you just
waiting for a live bait feeder can i
just
[Music]
every few minutes discarding any
leftovers must be restocked periodically
by
ranger teams like us different dinosaurs
require
different diets make sure to place the
correct type of
feeder in an enclosure i'm a red meat
man myself
ha ha that mean you're made of red meat
or what
what does that mean so that live bait
feeder you know it's gonna pop out
wait did one pop out already when did
one pop out did you guys see that get
eaten i bet you did i bet you do wow
look at the dino
it's so scary oh that's a nice detail
with the way the sun reflects off of
that
oh that's such a nice detail actually
play the game not like seven year old
you truly are
well just you wait because i'm only
building up to the point where i can
ruin absolutely everything it's it's
it's a coming don't you worry all right
let me see if i can get that hotel
contract please please pretty please
take this contract no
i'm not gonna do that please ah [ __ ] all
right well that's
i tried i tried and it didn't work ac
acu center that sounds important that's
probably important
you waiting he's waiting isn't he he's
so smart
it's that bird dna that i put inside of
him oh
ooh go to fossils all right we got
silver sell that
let's see more dna and oh good dna all
right we're going to get that and then
we need another expedition
uh partially depleted does that mean
that we can go again and it's okay
i mean if it's partially depleted that
means it can still go but i don't know
if it's gonna be like a reduced
deficiency or anything like that
are you still come on there we go
all right enclosures one item available
electrified light steel
sounds pretty wait what oh i need more
power that's right i do need more power
okay
do i need to just build another small
power station probably
five hundred five hundys
five hundys five hundo hundys are you
kidding me
and squad oh
okay once that's done we should be
plenty of power
and a plenty of moolah but a lot
less excitement you know what i mean
because i'm really really really like
i'm really pulling for some excitement
here and we're not getting it because
this is parks is doing okay but it's not
doing like great
it could be better it could always be
better upgrade the first power station
well that sounds impossible
i only have outage protection and i
don't even know what the baseline outage
protection could be
what what is the outage possibility for
this i don't even know but it's not
expensive so i'll get out of protection
sure whatever uh that's through the
power upgrade
fossils that's pretty good but we
already have a lot of that dna
let's sell this one and extract from
this one
because it's higher quality anyway okay
now that this is here what can i do
oh i can sell my dinos now but i don't
want to sell my dinos
um i'm guessing i should just get more
right just incubate more dinos these are
great can these can triceratops i wonder
what would happen
right what would happen what happened if
i put a triceratops
in with another dude
you think they'd be okay because this
one's tiny it's tiny little baby it
ain't gonna
it ain't gonna do nothing but if i want
to start a fighting pit okay he's gonna
have camo
yeah he's gonna have camo because you
don't even gonna see him
tooth hardness oh oh he's gonna have
some hard teeth
oh more attack on him oh we're gonna
have a fighting pit baby
skin toughness oh oh yeah oh wait this
one gives more defense though but less
viability
i like intensive repair i like that all
right let's see if this one's gonna work
i don't know if it's gonna work but
we're gonna try our burst
we're gonna try our best we're gonna get
two of these bad boys going in here just
in case
oh yeah oh yeah jeremy michael sarah
you're about to meet your match
oh you're gonna see this i strongly
suggest you consider taking
this contract okay all right thank you i
don't know why
but thank you i i think i'm already
doing that aren't i aren't they already
doing that so that's just gonna be free
money anyway
all right let me see if i can get
another contract this is a side hustle
that we should get
behind okay ooh taking a picture from a
feeder that might be cool so how do i do
that and why is this not pumping out
more incubation
oh did we fail oh no one of your
dinosaurs has failed to incubate
i never said bringing back dinosaurs was
going to be easy
we'll try again i want two of them but
this costs a lot of money
there's a lot of money that you're just
pumping out on me didn't i see something
about like a picture being taken or
something like that
or was it the ranger team that needed
that i think it was the ranger team
uh but i don't know oh i do have enough
money for that okay because i'm making
so much every opportunity comes with
risks
for now you've done the first that is a
job well done
thank you thank you
thank you woo
million labradorian i've got a new
assignment that i think is perfect for
your skill set
right give it a once-over then
let me know if you're interested million
million
million glad to have you on board
as you can imagine the animals in the
various facilities are constantly
probing for weaknesses in our security
systems
they're smarter and more devious than
people give them credit for
but i refuse to underestimate their
capabilities
that's why i'm always testing and
evaluating our security protocols and
barriers
this is where you come in i've got to
give this guy lambert his due
he actually sees these animals as both
opportunity
and threat yeah yeah that seems about
right considering that they uh they're
about to fight
again i need you to extract enough dna
from fossils to incubate and hatch a
dinosaur
are you know what i'm not gonna waste
any more money i'm gonna send
i'm gonna send this guy out there i'm
gonna save
before i do that we're gonna do like uh
the we're gonna call this one how do i
name it can i not
save okay here we go my career all right
the calm before the
the calm before i have no more
characters
okay all right here we go all right
let's do this release this dino
all right you go get him you go get him
you go you show him what for oh you're
big
oh yeah you're big you got big head you
got big horns you got big face
they ain't no see you there ain't no see
you face yeah you ain't no
oh yeah you ain't no one to mess with oh
you ain't no one to mess with
oh you ain't no one to mess with go
fight
you've had some triceratops might be
cute now
but that's only gonna last for about a
week oh yeah oh yeah
shut up fake chris pratt oh we're gonna
call you i'm gonna call you terry
terry terry bruce i'm gonna call you
your name is terry bruce
oh yeah oh you get it get it get it
[ __ ] fight him
there's a fight between michael sarah
and terry bruce
hell yeah yeah oh yeah
i'll fight fight baby fight i'm fighting
everyone's looking at the fight
oh yeah you're gonna run away little
baby are you gonna you getting your ass
handed to you oh you're getting your ass
handed to you well you're getting your
ass
destroyed there's a new king of the
jungle here
oh yeah you might want to back down yeah
oh terry bruce ain't looking for no
mercy you've been on these islands
before on isla new black
i made some mistakes and i've tried to
set them right
i believe in what we're doing and i
believe in these dinosaurs oh no
oh no terry bruce terry bruce strike a
decisive blow
you must take care of your dinosaurs
health is a vital importance
oh they stop fighting they stop fighting
they stop fighting look they can
cooperate
look there's peace in the jungle after
all look i think they're falling in love
oh i think they're about to fight again
no no terry bruce
uh oh oh oh oh oh
dairy bruce no no terry bruce
no no terry bruce oh no
oh terry bruce
oh he fought a good fight
he fought a good fight terry
we'll always remember you terry well
everyone's getting a good show
they did their best but in the end
only one can win okay let's make another
dinosaur
all right let's do let's do more of
these big boys we're just gonna make it
like
big boy land this is just gonna be big
boy land do i have enough money for that
i barely do let's make it big boy land
do i have any more genomes that i can
put in here no
no i do not i need 85 to be able to do
that
still bird brain still bird brain very
bird brain okay
incubate and that's all we're gonna do
for now
all right now he will become
terry poo's dion07 that is the
funniest thing next you are the animal
in a hammer recreation laboratory before
releasing and housing it in an enclosure
you'll also want to make sure we've got
an acu presence on this island mm-hmm
okay so you want me to make you want me
to make one of these
and then release it is that what you're
saying now be very careful about what
you're saying because i will do that
man they're going to eat for days i
guess died in a fight with michael
stewart just look at that text
died in a fight with michael sarah yeah
okay all right terry bruce
whoa whoa wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa jeremy jeremy come on now
add task what tranquilized jeremy
oh why no i don't need that no we don't
need that
where's the uh where's the picture thing
wasn't there like a picture thing
wasn't that like a thing that's
something that i needed to do photograph
a how do we how do we do that ranger
team
add task how do we how do we photograph
something
wasn't there a photograph i'm going to
make a new enclosure i will make a new
enclosure but i want to know how to
photograph
because that was definitely a thing well
you know what i'm going to do is i'm
going to incubate one of these here
because that's 170 and if it works then
i'm going to make a million that's a
pretty good return on my investment even
if it eats it
pictures ranger team that's what i
thought so how do they
maybe oh
get out the way get out of my way
get one get out of the way
oh god get out of the way run
there's an emergency room i did not know
this was possible
get out of the way ow
all right yeah all right here we go
oh no okay we're gonna oh
back up oh oh well this is this is scary
okay no wait what what why why what did
i do what dinosaurs your guests want to
get up close and personal with
the thing is they can't construct
facilities to increase visibility
and keep visitors the right side of the
safety
okay i don't know i don't i don't know
what uh
hell oh my god run ranger team drive
go resupply good you're gonna okay we're
gonna i'm gonna take a picture of this
don't come on oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh please get this goat and not me
i love the music going on all right goat
oh you're gonna you're gonna get ayden
yeah get the goat not me not me not me
goat
here we go oh close
whoo pretty cool huh
pretty cool all right here we go all
right we're gonna get that picture not
me not me
don't dude there's a goat his goat right
over there pretty cool huh
welp all right oh we should probably get
out of here oh okay our brand nope nope
no problem
oh yeah we got i think that might be
michael sarah oh yeah yeah
and chomp oh yeah that's pretty good
i really hope that gate wasn't left open
all right
dead is that good is that good no
dinosaurs
well all right i guess we should get out
of here then huh oh
room miss me all right here we go
this is my new favorite thing about this
is my new favorite thing i i had no idea
that this was a part of the game
i had no idea this is so fun oh wait are
they gonna
i should probably wait and see if they
okay we're good we're good we're good
we're good
i wish there was a horn on this thing
because i think there's a hand brake
get out of the way get out of the way
get out of the way
[Laughter]
that's the way they dive they just
just died that they did all right all
right here we go
here we go all right good luck out there
uh edmund tosaurus all right eddie
go get him go get him buddy go get him
no one can stop you oh you look so
stupid you are the dumbest
you are the dumbest looking thing i've
ever seen oh my god go get him
you got him herbert
[Music]
all right go get him buddy go ahead go
get him
right this next bit is going to sound a
little crazy because frankly
it is but we are going to encourage one
of the dinosaurs to breach our
containment grid
we'll then react and see if our
procedures and personnel
are up to the challenge yes so at this
point i'd like to take back everything i
just said about this
yes yes i love this man this man is a
great man
this man is great man this man is a
great great man smart man or a great man
great man smart man smartest great man
that ever smarted
he is a smart man and he's great man
he's like
great man he is a great man he is a
smart man and he's a great man he's a
great smart man
i like this man this man is real smart
and great
or asset no not that not that one should
be your first port of call to
bring down a rampaging dinosaur not
eddie
i didn't care about eddie remember the
show must go on
this contract makes that possible not
eddie
eddie what are you doing are you mad
because i called you stupid looking
well i don't take it back i don't take
it back at all i don't take it back none
okay we have our runner time to tag
less than lethal but remember i don't
know this is just supposed to be a drill
i love him so much while i understand
the need to keep our security as sharp
as possible
this is not the way i would go about
doing it probably not my reading's going
to keep you safe doctor i'm happy to
discuss it at a later time
right now we have our hands full what
are you doing what are you doing eddie
eddie what are you doing what are you
gonna do eddie
a burr
oh god oh god oh god
oh god all right let's uh let's uh let's
um
pilot the helicopter here we go get out
of the way
all right i'm slightly dull oh my god
i'm slightly drunk slightly drunk
here we go let's get him oh yeah oh
my god here we go all right and head
shot okay
head shot indeed oh my god i'm so good
at this
oh you suck ass i am so good there was a
zoom
didn't even need it uh i do a 360. hang
on do a 360. wait okay here we go
here we go
i need to call in the offshore transport
team to safely move this dinosaur back
to its enclosure
hell yeah all right coming in for a
landing
coming oh no hang on comment comment
comment in for
coming in for coming in for a landing
excuse me uh-huh coming for landing
coming in for a okay
coming in oh boy
come and hang on let's see if i can dart
it let's see if i can dart a guest
[Music]
did i get somebody
coming in for a lando and i guess we're
done
sure that that was that good enough okay
we need to
pick him up that what we need to do add
task
transport uh this dude
this one select destination
can we sell them then can we sell how do
we sell them
no how do we sell no come on how do we
sell
i want to sell him transport eddie sell
him off-site
how do we sell him mmm sell him just
throw him in the ocean
sell him oh i want to sell him so badly
well uh if he goes back in here he's
just gonna
die but how do i i want to sell them
well we're putting it back in there
and he's going back in the pan
and he's going back in the pen and he's
going back in the pen
oh look at that oh that's so nice that's
so nice oh
wait don't sell eddie it's either cell
eddie or eddie gets eaten
eddie gets eight and i'm pretty sure
eddie would rather be sold and live in
some millionaire's backyard than be
eaten
i'm just saying wow look at that
ah good thing our ratings back up that
was that was real fun that was good that
was good i'm the good stuff there
i have another this guy well let's just
make it interesting for him
let's just make it interesting for eddie
like now there's three threats instead
of just two
two is bad and guaranteed death but
three that just makes it interesting
all right what are your name what's your
name buddy what's your name
what's what's your name buddy
okay you're han but you're you know
you're the third so you're han
trio i'm gonna call you han trio
okay so we got han trio
we did it good job everybody
yeah feel good about that one that's the
job finished
true and square true and square look the
thing is
we're still learning where our
boundaries are when it comes to keeping
these animals under control
god knows they're working out ways to
exploit our weaknesses
guess we'll find out who gets to the
limits of our abilities first
us or them never
exploitation versus security oh that's
potential
profit that he's panicking violence but
he's panicking
why why do you do this to me i'm just
poor eddie looks like eddie might
actually be able to survive because he's
just running away as fast as he can
i think he's faster so technically
speaking maybe it'll be you know okay
maybe it'll not be so bad i think
eddie's hungry we got to get another
bait feeder
but this one i think he's an herbivore
so let's build
herbivore feeder over here maybe i
should like divide it
something that might be smart
i'll build another observation let me
build another observation thing
and then i'll build uh a feeder
right in front of it that sounds pretty
good
poor eddie poor poor eddie i mean i
don't think eddie's gonna survive very
long but you know
maybe it'd probably be a good idea
maybe oh my god oh boy
oh finally oh go oh gosh
okay oh that's a boy eddie that's a boy
his health is still going down probably
because he's
always food is down okay eddie you are
you're a trooper you're a trooper eddie
how about i make another friend for you
eddie
would you like that i bet you'd like
that i need to get power to this bad boy
oh man eddie you know what i'm proud of
you
i'm really proud of you you've shown us
all
that uh life has more meaning than oh
[Music]
oh um
um well this is
uh this is a bit awkward there he is
okay eddie's doing better look at eddie
look at eddie
look at eddie look at eddie let's build
another eddie
let's build let's build more eddies
let's maybe if i make him more
aggressive
maybe if i make him more aggressive then
we could really get something
going here okay we're gonna have three
eddies let's actually modify the genome
because now it's not a waste of money
let's give them more defense let's do
the defense
and let's do whatever this is cardio
strength
sure all right okay you know they got no
defense
this guy's gonna die but it'll be it'll
be interesting to see anyway
and two of those guys good oh man we
just missed out on aggressive uh oh
um uh maybe we should cancel nope can't
cancel them all right well
oh good it failed you know that's that's
probably fine that's probably for the
best
let's um let's get that let's let's get
um
let's get the let's just remove eddie
thank you can you remove
eddie can you get eddie uh can you get
eddie out of there eddie uh
eddie's daddy eddie is very deadly and
uh eddie uh
eddie's uh eddie has seen better days
is just what i'm trying to say there
eddie is dead
electrified fences that sounds pretty
good i think these guys are not only
learning but they're getting more
aggressive with timing okay
there's a new job available okay cool
oh god oh it's so sad oh no it's so
sad oh no why is his mouth hanging open
oh it's so
sad oh it's so sad oh that's so sad
oh no oh okay bye
oh boy oh that's so sad i think we need
more more um more
uh live bait feeder let's
put this bad boy right right um
too close to dinosaur yeah you know
probably
let's put that right there oh boy that's
so funny though
it's so funny no it's not funny it's not
funny well you know what's even more
funny
here comes uh here comes ed with two d's
not eddie here's ed
skip that because we're you are not
going to last long so
let's just uh this is this is um
hurry up please you you really need to
skedaddle you are you
you're wasting precious moments of your
life right here right now ed double d
you are uh oh here it comes down here
was originally uncovered at a site in
canada i'll let you guess where
the t-rex thinks these are delicious and
who's to argue
the t-rex thinks that these are
delicious
they really do they really do they
really do
they really do this is true okay i'm
sorry
that just caught me off guard because
it's like every time
every time they say something every time
they say something it pertains to how
i'm
screwing everything up it pertains
exactly
to how i'm ruining these these dinosaurs
lives in horrible ways
okay storm defense we've got that eddie
ed double d
oh no
[Laughter]
i feel bad okay we're gonna get uh let's
remove it remove double double d did not
last long
did not last the only reason now that
i'm thinking that eddie lasted so long
is because the game wanted eddie to
escape
and uh yeah that didn't uh that didn't
go over well
okay let's extract and extract okay
and let's build a hotel hell
yeah let's do it all right where can we
build it i don't know why is it
obstructed
what's obstructing it is it the the
water can i terraform that there was a
terraform
ooh there was a terraforming thing let's
see
shrubs well that's now that's in the
water that
that doesn't help me let's little
flatten
wow smooth
that down a bit
smooth that ah that's better
now it should work now we're gonna get a
hotel
people are definitely one of gonna want
to stay here for a long
long long time yeah just a
happy little accident dinosaur escaping
happy little accident all right hey we
got it
no it's only viable now we need more
we need more all right so we got that
guests are going to be happy we're
making moolah we're making so much money
god we're making so much money
oh look at us look at us
all right we need a picture of a
dinosaur eating from a feeder so let's
get the
jeep crew out there again
get out run get out
whoa okay ramp wasn't there before
excuse me
excuse me okay i'm pumping out goats
like it's my job
i don't know how many more goats i can
get out here someone eat a damn goat
how many goats can i get out here how
many goddamn goats do you need
dude oh yeah he's locked on target yeah
go go ah
no no no no you don't need you don't
need me come on what are you thinking
you want a goat i'm sorry okay wow all
right wow
rude oh oh get it go get it go you gonna
go you gonna go hang on i need a picture
of it
no where ah if i can chase down a goat
oh i can't it won't let me run over a
goat it
it keeps slowing down right in the
middle of it ah
i need a picture eat a damn goat there
goes no oh
hit it yes oh it's going for it this is
going for it
yes ah that's a good one
nice blum
can't wait to see that
all right everybody want to build a
situation go away chris pratt truly
trust you
and there are times when you have to let
them run free even when that means they
want to kill
that's what they need to do okay all
right thank you fake chris pratt thank
you so much
get out of the way look out the
dinosaurs
somewhere i don't know uh i shouldn't
have terraformed here
oh boy excuse me pardon me pardon me no
one's diving out of the way which they
should be
i got it cool all right we got our hotel
up and running hotel
two does it remember the loss of hotel
one
is that what it remembers uh what does
this mean
building can i upgrade the not the gate
can i upgrade the fences
upgrade mode ah replace on
can i replace whoa
okay well that's expensive oh my god
that is expensive
too close to dinosaur oh not enough
power anyway
well i did something so i feel good
about that but i didn't do a lot of
something
if you fossils let's extract you let's
suck you out of there that's what i did
but but
dude how do i research the gyro platform
i want to do that
what do i need unlock conditions not met
oh i need to get the entertainment up
well how do i get i can't get the
entertainment up
until i get the right things well you
want me to make another dinosaur pen
do i really have to do that
all right i guess i have to do that then
it's making me so how do
i do that huh i don't exactly have a lot
of
space here oh i guess i got space out
here
this job ain't easy but then it's not
supposed to be
we are reshaping the world one exhibit
and feeding time show at a time
this genome thing was solid work way to
bring it home
oh thanks man that makes me feel so good
thank you
we're gonna make big changes here we're
gonna we're gonna terraform
this whole area we're gonna turn it into
the next area that we're gonna have
let's smooth it out
smooth nice and smooth
okay let's get rid of the trees
bam eco terrorists here this is going to
be the this is going to be the herbivore
area this is going to be the the baby
dinosaur land
you know how it is okay we're gonna once
i once i define
like the actual like fence line then i'm
gonna come in and then i'm gonna
actually
uh make it prettier i'm gonna make it
nicer i
am i am gonna do that i'm a nice guy who
likes nice things and this nice guy
is gonna make it real nice all right
i know we're gonna delete this
and we're gonna we're gonna take
advantage of a bit more land here we're
gonna because i don't need to do all of
that
just yet we can have these button up
against each other a little bit which
might be a bad idea considering that
these dinosaurs probably
don't want to do that but you know it is
what it whoa
oh the burr oh no the all the birds oh
this poor family oh wish we bought a map
yes that's what it's gonna be okay oh
an offer just came our way okay sure
don't let it sit too long
why why not why why
what would it matter if it did this
opportunity pass you by
what what what what what what kind of
ominous [ __ ] was that what the hell
don't let this opportunity to pass me
about why wha what the hell
that was creepy okay all right well then
all right now we're gonna build a fence
line
and it's going to be
cool where where's like the uh
it was like that defining part of the
fence where do i
wait should i have built a fence first
and then built a
research center that feels like it may
have been a little bit of a better
choice or maybe i gotta wait until it's
done
either way i know it's gonna be okay
it's done now so
oh the fence there it is okay this is
the fence line cool all right so the
fence
we're gonna start with like an electric
ah too expensive we're gonna start with
a light seal fence these are
nice creatures there there's nothing to
worry about how do you curve something
by the way
because if i want to do a nice curve
like that how do i curve it how do i
space
oh wait it says it says right on the
instructions oops
uh i'm dumb okay all right that's fine
though i can't see
where it is but i'm assuming that it's
all
gucci yeah it's gucci there we go
who would want just a straight normal
boring offense
i mean me but whatever
oops i uh missed my target okay let's
hang on get rid of that
uh yeah that's good enough that's
probable that is that
is that enclosed that does not that does
not look enclosed okay
let's get rid of the trees here so i can
actually see what's going on okay you're
gonna go there
a nice there we go okay now we got oh
that's a nice space
that's nice space okay so we're gonna
have a nice little
pond at the bottom we're gonna actually
make a divot first we're gonna
lower this it's gonna be a nice pond at
the base of this hill
like if i could build a waterfall in
this i would you know i would
okay that's as low as it can go
apparently and add water
spl oh it just split oh it
well kind of there goes my plan huh well
they're they're they're uh there's
my plans is kind of out the window
because you were too much of an [ __ ]
to consider my feelings
all right whatever that looks good i
guess it looks good
whatever okay let's add some shrubbery
along the banks there along the banks
there
oh yeah this is good stuff good it's
looking a little sparse up here let's
let's uh let's fill that in yeah that
looks good
there and we got a lonely tree over here
nothing to worry about all right and
then we're gonna make two observation
centers
one yaw on the left and then one here
on the right see how i do it's beautiful
oh yeah there we go now we're in
business
oh i love that curved i love that curved
i love that curved okay
this is looking wonderful this is
looking wonderful all we got to do
is incubate some nice
eddies do we actually want eddies do we
is is eddie what we want is eddie
actually what we want i have no idea if
eddie is actually what we want
oh this is not connected to that oh
that's why it's a problem oh we're right
we're out of power okay
a load of [ __ ]
disease i just put down power how am i
diseased
oh wait no it's because there's no power
oh wait we're out of power
oh oh [ __ ] god ah dude let me click what
i want to click
dinosaur on your hands it's time to
trade it
or what comes next that's going to be on
your hands as well
um it's going to be on my hands you
talking about the poop are you talking
about the poop that's going to happen
okay who's got his disease you
you hey jeremy was it from all those
humans you were crunching
listen jeremy listen you piece of [ __ ]
listen
i've had it up to here okay all right
listen i owe you for this
oh shut up forget it ah shut up i'm not
talking to you
you go away i've gotta i don't to talk
i've got a sick dino i've got a million
interesting opportunity for you to
consider
it will allow us to work together to
create life
pure life if you've been listening to dr
malcolm
then you know how important this is to
us and to me
all right well you know i was originally
upset but then you waved a million
dollars in front of my face
and you know you know that'll get my
attention
hell yeah yeah all right anyway how do
we do this do we gotta go get uh an
expedition do we gotta tranquil i knew
you were my kind of person
inquisitive driven and i knew you
couldn't resist this opportunity
so let's get started uh all right well
i'm gonna get in the i'm gonna get in
the car
i'm gonna get in the car shut up
everybody out of the way
all the way out of the way the other way
boom boom boom
we got a sick dino on our hand i love
the driving
this is actually pretty good driving
mechanics for a game
yeah it's pretty funny all right here we
go great strides
oh they want to try certainly
at least
jeremy where'd you go jeremy jeremy i
don't know which one's jeremy how am i
supposed to be able to know which one's
jeremy
is that you jeremy okay oh that's jeremy
medicate him
got him we need to medicate that animal
if you are to save it
oh you you juked me all right here we go
all right we're going for it we're gonna
get him oh jeremy you can't run for me
you can't run jeremy i love the
medication delivery system
all right we're gonna get you we're
gonna get you all right get ready get
ready jeremy
oh [ __ ] gotta lead the target more
humble ah
[ __ ] where'd you go oh you think you're
gonna oh oh
run now oh my god
okay
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i'm sorry yay whoa whoa whoa
oh welp i guess we're done controlling
that one
okay so no power here we need to put in
the upgrade module we have that
we need to put improved outage
protection
by and then uh output protection or in
in in production yeah you guys
understood what i'm saying right
i can name the hotel or i want to call
this one um
uh scenic uh dino
[ __ ] look out uh
yup that's good okay so that's the
scenic dino [ __ ] lookout
all right so we need i think they said
triceratops right that's what we need
because i can get triceratops yeah it
looks pretty good i'm pretty sure that's
that's gonna be fine have i get i gave
this guy a modified genome right
yay oh yeah yay i did okay let's get two
of those bad boys going
one of them probably gonna fail some
things come up that could be interesting
okay
and profitable if there's
one thing that we like here it's money
i always like to have money i want to
get another expedition center
or i want to figure out a way to upgrade
this so that i can have more expeditions
maybe i'll research something along
those lines hey get the smart people all
in the room and let's actually try to do
something with our lives
okay so we need to get more we need to
get more [ __ ] going before we're
actually able to do anything
oh success rate oh that did that's
really good yeah i've been having some
bad successes right lately so
if i can get more that'd be that'd be
really worth it all these dinos keep
dying on me
all right where's the triceratops there
he is
let's go to hell creek i like the sound
of hell creek really matches up with the
kind of hell that we're in right now
okay so those are ooh they're ready
oh terry bruce is back baby
terry bruce died a horrible death chica
did you hear that terry brews
terry bruce chica what do you think wait
chica come on what do you think
wow wow it's a dido whoa
oh terry brews is back with a vengeance
baby oh yeah terry bruce we've been
monitoring
what you've been up to with great
interest and i'm a little disappointed
that dr dua came to you for this
assignment instead of bringing
me into the loop as she should have done
who the hell are you discuss this with
her later who the
who the heck hell are you who who are
you who are you oh no he's gonna eat
terry bruce is gonna get his oh he's
gonna get his munch on
oh hell yeah oh terry bruce oh [ __ ] yeah
oh who are you named who you gonna be
i'mma call you
spingleton yeah you look like a
spingleton all right
all right so this is uh this is
spingleton
move move i didn't put a gate in um
whoops let me put a gate and get uh
yup okay all right that's good all right
let's go
[Music]
you want to eat you want to mount you
want to go crouch
you want to crouch to the plants hey hey
buddy
well wait huh let's zoom in really give
me a look give me a look
oh yeah that's a good look oh yeah
that's good oh yeah
that's good all right fine i'll have
them waiting in there for my
opportunity to strike whenever they get
hungo they're going to have to go over
there
they're going to have to do that because
if they ain't hungover
they'll kill him i'm just gonna kill him
i can get more dinos in here
let's get the little guys cause i
wait no we got more fossils let's make
sure that we get the fossils first
just whoa look at us oh
hell yeah look at this very high quality
[ __ ] going on here
oh oh hell yeah okay that's cool that
was a good expedition
uh we're gonna build one of you you're
going in there
i'm gonna build one of you you the dumb
doofy looking one you go in there all
right so we got those guys
and are you oh where'd my oh did the car
already go back
all right the car already went back but
i'm not gonna drive it over again until
i get more in there and then i know
that i'm gonna need them okay maybe i
should get more of those
things maybe i should get more of those
i mean more is good right more is
definitely gonna be good
there's no way that having more of these
things is in any way bad
right hey oh go
go go oh
little guy oh
another dinosaur that furthers the case
of a direct
linkage to our modern birds there's
meemu
there's meemu all right cool your
reputation with the science division is
impressive oh it's eating oh no go
go go go go go go we gotta go
take it take it take it take it boom got
[Music]
you are it us and yourself look good
oh man i always make myself look good if
there's one thing that i do
it's look good literally all times all
right
it died okay let's make another one of
these things let's make another big
doofy dude
all right that one's gonna be ed with
one d i hear those photographs you took
were
excellent so yeah you can call that
contract complete
oh yeah again whoa
that is gross ooh we can make a hwang
oh go go me moo go momo this one will be
momo that was mimu this one's momo
this is momo everybody say hi to momo
momo's a real charmer
okay that's momo that's mimu no that's
that's terry bruce that's me moo that's
momo
one will be mamu
momo mimi mimo mumbly
and then meme incubate we're almost to
the triceratops dna we just need
one last expedition with it to be able
to go oh yeah release it oh this one's
ed
ed the loner always by yourself no
friends anywhere oh you big dumb doofy
looking dino
oh look at this stupid-ass face on this
dumbass dino
sir i've heard oh i've heard that
there's
horrible monsters here oh i hope
i hope not oh god where are my friends
where's double d and this one's just ed
it's ed oh boy hello hi
what
[Music]
yes site c more commonly known as
isla muerta a newly developed island
the name roughly translated then i do
mean roughly
the island of the dead
fitting humorous even humorous even
humorous oh humorous all right should we
go
should we go to the new island you guys
think we should go to the new island
yeah you guys think we should go to
death island oh yeah
no preach for mark because i'm a big
bully
i just feel i feel unpreached
i think i'm gonna leave this real bully
here the bully's here
[Laughter]
all right beware of dangerous storms as
they can cause terrible devastation to
your island operations
historic creatures
this next island isla you may have
some meteorological events you know
storms
that kind of thing
see the weather on this island can be a
little
first thing you're going to want to do
is fix any damage this storm has caused
you should use a ranger team to get the
park operational again
oh and don't forget to close any
emergency shelters when it's safe to do
so
guests won't spend their hard-earned
dollars huddled in a bunker underground
will they huh must have been quite the
storm
and it seems that bad weather is often a
precursor to bad behavior
from the dinosaurs if you believe that
everything is connected
the so-called butterfly effect and i do
believe it by the way
then one small change is all it takes to
create a series of toppling dominoes
leading to rampaging dinosaurs
and they don't make a butterfly net big
enough to stop them
uh okay thank you jeff goldblum thank
you for that all right we're gonna get a
ranger team i guess
that looks expensive you should get that
fixed and soon
all right okay team is equipped for that
do i shoot darts at the building
all right you better get fixed here wink
all right that oughta do it okay let me
fix that ac unit
all right got that one this tower looks
in need of repair
blink oh it's unpowered oh that's the
only problem with it okay well
uh oh it's technically got a substation
we just need to repair the substation
okay i did i missed something because i
have no idea how to repair a substation
hmm i uh hmm
[Music]
oh maybe i got a oh maybe i gotta drive
this too because this wasn't
disrepaired it was it was just not
powered so maybe i go
to the can
what why couldn't i go forward there
well that made no sense okay whatever
repair that prepare in progress
okay we got that all right i still think
my old dart method should have been the
one that was actually gonna get it
oh that ain't good
okay that's good ah
okay all done here oh
good job well done i'll leave them there
they can make their way back home
so we got all that repaired and then we
need to close shelter
close all shelter we apologize for any
inconvenience experienced
during our recent handling of anomalous
events our recent handling of anomalous
events as if
like it was was it not good did we not
do good did
we do it badly so what we're gonna do is
we need to get some dinos going do i
still have all of my uh do i still have
all my yeah
i do all right we're gonna make one just
truth imotho
struthemiomus only we're gonna just have
like
out the wazoo of how many strumio thozos
we have
we're gonna have so many streamiomamos
okay we also need to get the actual
expedition center going we need an
expedition center um
let's have all this wait where's the
edge of our okay we don't want to build
too far over there let's make let's
intelligently
think about where we want all of our
stuff and i am
intelligently thinking that wow this
island's whoa this island's
big oh my god this oh my god
oh my god okay this island's huge so i
don't want to build over there because
i'm obviously going to expand over there
i think here is probably my best bet for
keeping things relatively
in line with one another okay and
baduski
the fossil center to be able to produce
those we need to build a road to get
over there
probably let's build a nice curvy boy
yeah oh that looks nice
oh no one can tell me that don't look
nice because that looks nice
other nice okay we've got a fossil
center
curvy boy okay good we got that fossil
center's going up let's go ahead and
extend
out those peducions nice
new fossils discovered hell yeah go for
that all right
go get it get out of here just get out
of here
just get out of here oh release the
dinos yes
mimu and momo are back back in business
oh
shut up all right release the other one
and skip it as well because i just i
can't be bothered
you're meemu that's mimu
the other one's momo are we releasing
the other one is this is happening
hey momo i'm i'm stuck on you i guess we
literally can't do anything until you're
done doing your freaking
stupid [ __ ] all right momo you
freaking drama queen
all right there's momo oh let's get two
more going and
flumpo here all right that's gonna be
moomo and mumbly
what we need what we need is a burger
stall that's what we need
that seems like ideal priority my minor
curvy boy oh release the dino
i just don't care okay release the dinos
okay those are getting released i'll
name them when they're done
we need we're running low on money but
not that low
research center okay there all right
and then a road and then we are good on
the operations [ __ ]
the stuff that nobody cares about we are
good to go on that one all right
cool oh look at him run okay we need to
get him food
ground herbivore that sounds pretty good
all right
oh those were expensive why are they so
expensive maybe because you're
supposed to only need one and i
accidentally bought like 10 billion of
them
under construction power consumption we
need more power okay so we're gonna need
to get a more
powerful power i have no money i have no
money
why don't i have more money hello
okay cool thank you oh man it's not even
two yet i'm
br i'm not broke i'm not look ad revenue
is a little down admittedly but you know
it's it's fine i'm going to drive this
ranger team
into the enclosure and uh you're going
to see i'm going to get money other way
it's not an emergency but i feel like
rushing anyway where oh he was on the
other side all right get ready to get
your picture token
here we go picture taken bam gotcha
one's panicking you guys gonna eat can i
get one of you eating
that'd be cool that'd be profitable all
right fine whatever you losers
whatever get out of here okay that was a
little bit of money but not even
remotely worth it let's make two more of
these bad boys
spend our money done none of these
should fail
they better not fail if they fail him
i'd be real pissed ooh
[Music]
you gotta shut up i already know what
i'm doing bam baby okay easy peasy easy
money can i say
you did good thanks man
thank you all right shut up okay wait oh
wait i gotta i gotta name these guys
okay
you're you're a muumuu this one's moo
moo we got me
moo moo moo momo where's the other one
there
you are okay you're going to be moomin
you're going to be moomin
you're a moomie you're momu this is momu
everybody say adam omu and this
you are you're our mimi okay so we got
momo momu mumi mimi
and mimu there's gonna be a quiz on this
so you better you guys better get this
right you gotta memorize this mimu
mimi momu mumi mumu
and momo i don't like how they're all
talking to each other that's
i don't know if this is a good idea but
last oh wait this requires this hasn't
been powered this whole time well that's
why people couldn't even see that
we need power anyway maybe that wasn't
the power area but it just didn't have
enough power for it
because i have no money that's right i
was trying to get money for that and
then i was going up building other stuff
why was i doing that oh and there's no
power there
welp i seem to be in a bit of a
conundrum here i can't get power shut
the fast food down i'm sorry we got it
we got to turn it off to save enough
power so we can get
nope we can't get an expedition which is
the only thing that needs
ma that we need for money so let's turn
off the let's get the fast food going
people are going to be real pissed if
they
don't have food here all right so we got
that give
me power why do i not have power okay
this
doesn't need to be powered right now
there's nothing to see over there so
we're going to deactivate that
everybody hold on this is all worth it
we definitely don't need to power this
thing get that
out get that [ __ ] gone all right now we
can go get it
now we can go get what we need
a velociraptor
i want a velociraptor i want to put
veloso rupters
on the opposite side of the uh
the mimu and momos and momos and mima
momos
that we need so that they can just see
them from across this fence and just be
like
oh my god there's food over there
there's so much food it's just
this is endless endless food so we're
gonna get a new contract
we need science
is a new job available [ __ ] and i know
just the person to do it
me is it me are you going to give me
money because that's all i really care
about
money we're just kind of stuck for a bit
because i just kept
i kept spending too much money i just
need more power
that's all i need i just need wait it
says unused power 11. oh probably
because i shut those down
wait why did i need power in the first
place wait what did i need power for
again
i don't need power i've got power
i think what about my other island can i
just go to the other island is that
something i can do
no i don't think that i don't think you
can do that it's like playing a theme
park game you got only one park at a
time right
hello are you all right there
hello how are you no dinosaur
oh no matter what i think i just i can't
figure it out there's no dinos in this
picture well that's a good pick
oh that's a good pick give me my money
give me money
uh 24 is perfect i'm gonna get there
eventually
oh munch please munch munch i need the
munch yes
munch munch crunch and munch crunch it
crunch yeah
this is [ __ ] i deserve more money
than this oh my expedition's back
okay good all right we need to send
people off to uh
more velociraptor and then uh we need to
research the velociraptor
we got this oh hell yeah oh we got some
amber oh well yeah
a gift shop hell yeah
you know that's what people want there
right by the emergency shelter so no one
needs to be worried
when they're in the shelter they can
still get their shop on
i kind of spend too much money on the
operation so i'm going to go ahead and
i'm going to demolish this guy get the
money back
we don't need that let the mother humper
burn
what we do need is more dinos
that's what i know for a fact so let's
incubate some more of these guys
and we'll be real good cause i don't
think those guys are gonna be like any
sort of a threat to me
right okay all right i'm gonna release
those and we're gonna name them if i can
get to him
i want to take this contract which means
you want to take it too
correct okay all right sure whatever you
say man
we need mommy mommy okay mommy okay you
you're this is steve okay so we got
moo moo mommy mimu mimi
momo mummy and steve okay everybody got
those remember there's gonna be a test
you better be brushed up on what you got
going on here so we need
to research these oh yes
that's a lot of money oh hell yeah my
guys oh
they oh i am so proud of you
okay but what we need to do is we need
to eventually i don't know how much
we're going to get out of this one
we may be able to try to make a
velociraptor but it's probably going to
end up in failure if we don't get it
right so
you know i don't want to risk it if
we're not going to get it up to there
but you never know with anything that we
got going on
so that's not actually the t-rex by the
way for those of you who are thinking
that was a d-rex last time
stupid wrong i think this is the t-rex
no that's the t-rex
oh look there wait i want a picture of
that i want a picture of that hang on
everybody out of the way there we go
here we go
all right zoom and ah
yes no no
are you are you [ __ ] kidding me okay
here we go
yes yes look at the money
that's some good money oh yeah oh yeah
give me that money
it's just the same picture over and over
again
okay cool all right that's all i needed
now they're back
and that's good we need more of a loosey
rooty and uh
let's uh fossil them up okay extract
and uh it's shitty quality let's just
sell that one
and as soon as we get those done we
should be able to do that we can build
another power station now which is good
i'm gonna do that
we got that we got good power over there
we got good power over here
we can start unlocking this stuff we can
activate that as soon as well we're not
gonna have power for it but we can
activate it so that we will have power
eventually
we have those dinos over there the
ratings not the best
in the world what else could we make we
need
clothes hell yeah
okay all right got it okay as soon as
you're done
and more velociraptor
go go go go there we go
okay oh we didn't even get to go to the
bathroom
so how much does it cost to make a
velocirup
how much
are you [ __ ] me that's more than a
serotops
in what world in what
in what cock-smacking world
and what in what world is that
right in what are you
who even are you who do you think you
are
six hundred thousand six hundred
thousand good god
oh all right whatever i'm gonna make
this guy
i'm gonna make this guy we're gonna make
two of these guys i don't have enough
money for it i just don't have the money
how the hell am i gonna get more money i
want more money
i've got no money guys i've got no money
i've got no
don't have any money i'm so poor
if this egg fails to incubate i'm i'm
just sunk i'm sunk i can't
there's no way just i won't be able to
do nothing
i'll be i'll be washed up i guess i
could make a huang
or i could look up the ankles i should
have but i guess i should have been
doing
i should have been doing my contracts
that would that would have been a smart
thing to do
wow why haven't i been doing that what
about my missions where are my missions
oh all right i don't know you know this
is a bunch of bologna
can i i can't even get another contract
because i haven't been doing what i was
supposed to be doing
i'm so stupid i'm just i'm dumb why am i
making one of these when i should have
been making one of the hwangs
and i could have gotten the i could have
gotten the money
but i didn't i've got draco rex here
you are gonna be much smaller than i
thought you'd be you are
[ __ ] tiny
you're smaller than the memus
and what why why were you so expensive
you're not worth it oh don't roar you're
tiny
i am incredibly still the dragon king
the draco rex sounds so intimidating
but it's just a plant eater however just
in case they do
rule the earth again don't tell them i
said that
i'm gonna call you you're gonna be
malfoy
and i know that you would rather have
more social right now but to be
perfectly honest i just can't afford
making another one of you okay fine i'll
make another one of you
good god but i need to make i need to
make a huang but the huang might not
work because i don't have enough money
to risk two huang's
i just can't afford the hwangs i can't
even afford to go on an expedition
i gotta sell my fossils or something oh
avian fossils okay sell that that's good
let's sell this cause i'm not gonna make
up i'm not gonna make a velociraptor i
might as well not have gotten those
all right let's send them on an
expedition we're gonna eyeballs
get out of here where's the huang give
me here the huang
chong king chung king osaurus
all right sure whatever malfoy you son
of a tit
i am so unhappy with you you're gonna
you're gonna get a friend here
you're gonna get a friend i'm gonna
queue up uh let's queue up a huang
but we gotta give this huang a modified
genome because it needs the intensive
repair
so let's hwang it up with some repair
aggressive instincts here we go this is
what it needed right
all right we got the huang let's cook up
a hwang
you you're gonna be ron [ __ ]
weasley
we got mimi momo uh steve
momou momi mimu
malfoy and ron [ __ ] weasley
and i think that's only a pro theory we
got those in order uh the expedition
should be coming back we've got 71
thousand dollars somehow we keep
running out of money you know i don't
know why
it just kept happening all right you get
get ready to go right back out
[ __ ] yeah
that strutheomimus because we probably
need to perfect it even more don't we
okay what's this oh hell yeah silver
sell that
oh yeah oh hell yeah
oh oh good old low quality huang
all right we're gonna call you all right
what should we call
hwang here oh you are an ugly
you're an ugly guy oh you got kind of a
punk rock thing going on
oh okay all right well no need for a
little skip like that
okay hwang you made that look easier
than it was
it took a bit it took a bit of doing i
will admit it took a bit of doing oh all
right you're gonna huang
hai yang you're gonna be called mr
mr panu pinoodle
mr pinudlu okay everybody say hi to mr
p noodle my first instinct was just mr
penis all right we need to make another
one of those even though it's probably
gonna fail because the social is gonna
get real down on it
so we're gonna incubate another one of
these bad boys but i know it's gonna
fail uh oh
incoming storm well that's probably
that's probably not good shelter
coverage 92 percent
that's probably not good uh can we make
another one
250 i don't want to spend the money on
look look look it may only cover 93
92 but to be honest
let's open the shelter
look that eight percent how much could
those lawsuits actually cost me i just
can't afford the money
um you might want to turn around there
you guys might want to start running
hmm uh oh wait a minute that's that's
less than good let's get the repair team
going
can we add a task can you just repair
why it's already on fire it's just a
little rain
how did the light on fire how the frick
did you do okay we need ankylosaurus we
need
ankylosaur there we go oh boy that's not
good
where's my repair team where'd they go
you okay add a task
repair that all right
huh what dinosaurs the right environment
if they're going to thrive
ah shut up no one cares what you're
thinking what happened to my
there it is we're getting there we're
getting there mommy what's wrong with
mommy
oh it's comfort's going down it's
raining do you expect me to actually do
anything about the rain
i can't exactly stop that and it's
cleared up okay all right
it's over close all get out of here and
release
okay so there was mr pinaludalu
this one's going to be um
i've got an idea so we got mr
pinaludalu right and this one's going to
be called
another member of the stegosaurians
excuse me i'm in the middle of something
fence broken that's bad wait okay wait
my hilarious name has to wait
where are you ad task go fa yep that's
important can you guys uh oh no
not mr pete ludlu mr p and lulu's on a
rampage
uh how about can you guys um add another
task can you
can you tranquil i need uh i need a
difference i need the
right okay all right everyone back in
the shelter
back in the shelter um oh
[ __ ] god damn it mr peanut load lou ah i
need to build an apc but do i have the
money for it
the answer is no mr peanut
lou i had you a friend you had a friend
why can't you just cooperate
wait can i just drive this and uh what
happens if i uh
dart rifle okay here we go ah
oh not sick okay oops um
uh oh boy um um
oh i have enough money okay wait let me
see if i can sell anything more too
uh yes sell this and uh sell that oh
hell yeah and
extract that and uh yeah extract that
okay very high quality very high quality
okay let's build one of these things
hope you guys don't take
too long wild dinosaur mr p and ludalu
ain't too happy
see the thing is he's going to be happy
now i didn't have a friend for like that
long
that long and then mr p lulu goes on see
i mean mr peanut
he's he's happy now this freaking
[ __ ] this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] here we go acu
helicopter add task
no i'm gonna do this manuel mono there
we go oh right in the neck all right in
the neck
oh no oh crumpled in a rag doll heap
ah here we go okay get this guy move him
to back in the spot and now
everything's fine give me your money
okay is everybody else happy here you're
all happy
yeah you're all happy you're all happy
where's uh where's the other one okay so
as i was saying as i was saying oh
forest wait not do all these need forest
oh okay let's we don't need forest why
are then why are you standing
if you don't like forest then why are
you standing in the
forest that's your own fault that's your
old stupid fault just move
it's not my fault that you're standing
in the forest
oh is it not enough forest oh is it not
enough
i'm very confused do you want more for i
can make more
is is that what you wanted i'm assuming
this is what you wanted right
that's what i like about you you get
results okay sure
okay that's what i like about me okay
all right now that we got that taken
care of time for
your name mrs vagin
noodle the moment you've all been
waiting for
we've got mrs vegeta
and uh is he's still taking a little nap
is he still taking a nap in here it's
pretty dense forest in there
mr peanut and mrs vagina
no relation no relation right i'm pretty
happy with um
myself i'm pretty i'm pretty happy with
myself
something horrible has happened i don't
even have a research station
how do i get a research station i don't
even remember mr fujinoodloo
mr peanut this disease is spreading
faster than we can contain it
oh no oh god it's a horrible
horrible std those those two have been
having
raucous raucous raucous dinosaur sex
and it is just getting absolutely out of
hand yeah they are probably not doing
very good
okay let's send you out again we are not
doing good here
we are not doing good go over there
let's research these
and extract okay that should suffice for
the uh
the other requirement that we have over
there which is good and then eventually
we're going to get mr pinaludalu and mrs
vaginoodlu up and running but for right
now it's just going to be a bit of a
problem
excuse you i did not need you popping in
front of my face like this
we'll get to it in a second they're
probably going to die they're they're
probably going to die there's literally
no way that i'm going to be able to get
this built
and the research done in enough time to
be able to save
them all right we're going to try all
right
medical treatment let's get for
is this what wait which disease is it
okay what do you have
bracken bracken poisoning bracken
there we go bracken poisoning that
doesn't make any sense all right we're
gonna get the other
we're gonna get these guys where is my
ranger
where are my rangers oh you're over here
duh i wasn't even in the right place
okay you're gonna number one repair that
responding to repair
and then we're gonna once you do that
i'm going to take you over
and we're gonna go and we're gonna shoot
some dinos we're gonna shoot him good
then we should take some pictures too i
bet people would pay a lot of money for
a sick dino okay so we're gonna get the
dart gun out okay
you oh boink medication not research oh
well i'm boosting your health though
yeah there we go
oh god you're right in your butt ho ho
ho come back here hey look
look look look oh gotcha oh he's a fast
one he's a
you shouldn't have stopped gotcha all
right cool
oh i love this mitigation delivery
system
gotcha okay all right there's no
sources of bracken poisoning remain in
the park okay building available
what do we i'd got
suggest you consider taking this
contract i strongly suggest you
take considering this contract
the ability okay we'll do that one all
right so far so good
we need a dinosaur rating of 1.0
where is our dinosaur rating anyway
island rating dinosaur rating poor
variety great welfare okay
that's nice facility rating is good
responsible management of our animals is
key as is creating a safe environment
for our visitors
yeah i don't know about that second one
that second one probably isn't as good
as you think it is
well all right you know what i i guess i
should get some variety i guess
going which seems stupid seems really
stupid but whatever
maybe i should get some big boys maybe i
should get some big boys
oh yeah let's get some big boys going
let's get some big boys
i would have a better island rating if i
just got more dinos
so i'm i'm assuming that these big boys
are gonna help me get
what i need to do we can get another
contract so let's get another contract
entertainment i've looked this gig over
you should too perfect
there's no power for no power outages
for 10 minutes that sounds good
okay oh god damn it oh i didn't finish
my research
oh did i no i did oh that's stupid there
was such a small chance of that what
a what a piece of poop what a poop what
a
poop mouth with a poop poop face
which poop they're gonna be made and
that's fine i think this place is
probably getting a little too crowded
for them which is probably why
they're having some issues but once we
get these
other dinos up and running we can get a
carnivore area
so that we don't have to worry about any
any interference in between the two but
i still want to create a fighting pit
i think that's super cool it was too
weak
you you mother you
you piece of [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ]
too weak to survive i can't afford
another one
that was two that's two that's six
hundred thousand dollars
that just went down the drain that's 600
i
don't want to release one it's going to
be lonely
there's so much money you just threw
money i had
money now i don't have money because
you're an [ __ ]
all right it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine i don't have enough money i'll
release the one of them that'll probably
get my rating up because everyone is
going to be like
oh wow oh look at this
guy oh it's fine it's all good
you're gonna be uh you're gonna be
called poop
all right everybody
whenever i get upset i just come up with
the most childish
name i could possibly think
guess what i'm gonna name the other one
i'll give you a mil you can't guess
you'll never guess what i'm gonna name
the other one
dino bites oh
sell for ooh wait what
oh we're not managing this we'll get
some staff in there
management view we're gonna we're gonna
sell
lots of food we're gonna sell lots of
food we're gonna sell it for
eight bucks because of the service that
we got going dino
dino bites dino dish we got dino dish
here
oh hell i didn't know that you could
micromanage it like this i had no idea
oh those
the running causes are crazy okay we
don't need that many people we need
three
three good people that's what's gonna
get us okay we can sell
barbasol i don't know why we're going to
sell that bad boy for
20 bucks oh wait i need to increase the
price of the other one i did not know
that you could do this dino dish 20
books
you know you know people are going to be
willing to shell out for dino dish we're
gonna be
all about the shopping baby we're all
about the shopping
we actually we don't need yeah we don't
even need that many we don't oh okay all
right we got
we got this it's all good it's all good
okay you're gonna be you're gonna be
dino hats everybody loves dino hats
everybody loves dino hats but it looks
like we don't need any more of that but
we do need a food place
okay we got we had the ex moderately
expensive food now to get the cheapo
food the real
the real scoozy stuff and i i you know
people probably ask is a real dino and i
just go yeah
yeah they die they die a lot they they
die real fast
just i wish i wish they didn't die but
they do they keep
i'm not cut out to run uh i'm not gonna
i'm just i shouldn't be in charge that's
all i'm saying i i i really am
criminally negligent when it comes to
the survival of these beautiful
beautiful creatures i am
but anyway the burger is real yeah it's
absolutely 100 real
dino meat is what i'd say to them that's
what i say then that was my hypothetical
that i was saying to them
hey i got the complete genome whoo
oh yeah all right fast food two you are
gonna be dino bites but you are gonna be
selling them at a bit of a premium
we're gonna make it fun hell yeah we are
all about the fun baby
oh we are about the fun and we are
having nothing but fun lunchbox
get it for a bargain you are about the
fun
we are having fun here at gift shop too
we're gonna call this
uh big old boxes
get em wow they're
big okay we've got the store big old
boxes get em all they're
big uh this one's called dino bites
yes they are real they keep da
that they real please
eat corpse nope they are real pleasing
dino bites
yes they are real please eat all about
the fun baby
all about the fun these guys love me
here they love me being in charge oh
say depleted that's not good all right i
want to build another one of these bad
boys
build them i guess are you actually
happy are you happy
you could use a little more but you know
whatever all right don't
die just don't die
just don't die don't die
all i ask is that you don't die okay
you understand me triceratops just
don't die oh
you i you
god damn stupid that's
so much money that you're just throwing
away
you you're just you're just killing me
you're
killing me i'm trying to get i can't get
my
rating up because i don't have enough
dinos if i just get this
one dino i'd get two contracts done
they'd be
done they'd just be done and i'd be
done and there'd be nothing else but you
just gotta
die you're just you're just falling over
dying you're just dying just like you
can't even get out of the goddamn
egg i just don't understand i don't
understand oh
wait i gotta install this
okay that's fine 100 fine
all good not a problem
not a problem it's all right it's all
good it's all good you know
it's it's all good we're just gonna
throw that one in the trash start over
because now it's 99
look 99 chance possible
for a success that is literally no
chance
there is no chance it's going to fail
this is absolutely
100 going to work
and that's fine look i live and learn
i've got loves
i if it's fine it's 100 fine
my shop is making money we're really
balls to the wall about this
let's crank up these prices because i'm
all about the prices
look i gouge prices because people are
willing to pay for it and i'm going to
keep
keep gouging and it's going to be good
almost there almost there i'm really
nervous about it but it's
it's gonna work we got poop here we got
poo
and you know what this is gonna smash
he's gonna smash these ratings out the
window
they're gonna go right out the wazoo
release
yeah look at that oh my god
you're beautiful warm
wow and with that everybody say hello
to
everybody welcome uh by welcome p
[Laughter]
i'm gonna be good we got poop and we got
p
yeah that's a few too many e's i think
on p i got a little uh
a little excited on the e we got p p
and poop okay we didn't make it
up this is
all right you know what that's fine
because it's fine
let's just make some edmontons
let's make some edmontons let's make a
couple
edmontons cause that's what i'm looking
for and then we'll have our variety up
and then we'll have better
right great squad allah
and with that we have got this place
ready to go we're gonna oh i think
they're all like the ones that were
there before ed and nettie
they're dead so we need another trio i'm
gonna call
buffalo bubbles blossom and buttercup
got it okay
oh shut up hurry up we've got a line
going
uh if it's all about you then things are
not gonna go well all right you are
this is blossom everybody say how to
blossom
and then bubbles is coming out there and
then buttercup will be
buttercup will be on the way right about
now oh and never mind i don't have
enough money
are you gonna roar you're gonna be done
how do i not how do i
how is it oh it's up wait it's up wait
give me my money
give me my oh i need to do it for oh
okay all right this
is a butter this is bubbles
this is baubles these bubbles these
blossom
i should have just gotten one of the
carnivores because the carnivores are
always higher rated than these goddamn
[ __ ] not like these not like the
memo moo moos
pieces of [ __ ] do nothing for me a bunch
of garbage
dinosaur rating i think the reason that
my other dinosaurs were so highly rated
because they probably had a lot of
combat infamy
just from crunching all the guests so
there's really nothing that
nothing that i did it's just they they
were very vicious
very vicious okay and then um
how am i not island raiding i want my
island poor capacity
what poor capacity is it because i'm
pricing them too high
is that the problem is it because
they're too expensive is that what it is
oh no one's there oh okay no one's
buying it oh whatever
oh screw me then no one's buying because
it's so
expensive [ __ ] you all right whatever
we're gonna make it 12. that's
it seems totally fair that it would be
double the price of whatever it is is
that the reason
my my park has been going down is that
the reason
is that the reason is that the reason
because i feel like that's
really mean management view i thought i
told you the management view was fun
oh and i i saw that it just went back to
none
management view is fun it goes back to
how can you not know it's fun all right
that's buttercup
no our mission in raising these animals
is to provide an environment for them to
thrive
your habitat is too small for them how
do you know
how do you know it's too small how do
you know it's too small are you sure
it's too small maybe you're too small
you ever think about that you ever think
that you're too small
you ever think about that because you
might be you might be too small
i could either build more fence or i
could build a hotel and you know which
one i'm gonna be going for
stupid idiot my hotel is going up
they're not
they're not cooperating with me they
don't know i am all about the fun
i'm all about the fun this is a fun
place full of fun people
we're having lots of fun we're having
lots
of fun remember the show must go on
this contract makes that possible good
thank you you're gonna give me money for
putting down a hotel that just proves to
me that it was the right idea all along
all right i'm gonna make a bigger
habitat for these [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] we're gonna basically i'm
gonna do this in two stages i'm gonna
build it out
first okay don't let this go to your
head but that was some
very impressive work on that contract
wow thank you
thank you thank you very much i thought
as much
i suspected as much but i'm glad you
said it anyway
i knew it was really really impressive
work because it was
really difficult it was incredible oh
[ __ ]
huh all right well let's uh repair that
uh-huh
repair that uh-huh prepare that
are you gonna go are you going are you
going just run people over are you going
just
run people over man i wish i'm faster at
driving than these guys are
i don't know what they're doing being
all lollygaggy about it
okay so far so good i mean the dinos
probably ain't getting too comfortable
about it but
i think they'll be all right seems to be
clearing up all good
all good okay all right
get the hell out spend money okay i'm
gonna build bigger area for this one too
too close to dinosaur oh get out of the
way then you
[ __ ] get out of the way we got that
let's demolish this
that and this and that and we've got
much bigger places for everybody to roam
hell yeah you really killed it on that
contract
i killed it oh i killed it
islam murders entertainment division is
excelling because of you
so you're getting a reward on everything
what he got for you i have over a
million
oh i finally have over a million
guys guys guys i have a
guy they got over a million cool okay
all right cool i deserve it i do deserve
that that's that's 100
i deserve that 100 absolutely do
but also i got a bunch of stuff here
bird eggs that doesn't help anybody are
they sure that's a bird egg they're
pretty sure that's not
like you know an important egg 202
oh hell yeah i'm making so much money
okay this is going
really really really good really really
good
i probably need to make another shelter
at some point ooh
toy shop that sounds fun oh that sounds
super fun that's good are they wearing
hats oh i i thought those two hats for a
second okay
bubbles blossom wait wasn't buttercup
supposed to pop out didn't did buttercup
get scooted out of there
but butter buttercup didn't i have a
buttercup oh there you are
buttercup there you are there you go
okay all right we got that
that's good that's good this is looking
good that's looking good we are doing
really really good all right so what's
next to do what would be next to do
they said that the transportation in
this place ain't too good but
i don't exactly know how to build more
monorail like how would i build more
monorail
if i were just to be perfectly honest
about it because honestly i don't know
feeder needs resupply well that seems
important
oh we need more power i think i can
still put
modules into the new one over here yeah
i probably can
add output okay that's a little bit more
but not
that much it'll it'll keep us it'll keep
us good for the time being until i can
get more stuff
we could build a new zone and actually
get some carnivores up in here which is
what i want to do
we could probably do it over here in
carnivore land okay let's build
let's do exactly that let's because we
oh
look how much space we're gonna make
this all oh
yes oh hell yeah okay we're gonna make a
carnivore land but it's gonna have like
a
there's also going to be a wrapping uh
uh observation road
that's gonna have a bunch of observation
decks but before we do that i need to
deforest i need to absolutely destroy
all of the beauty of this land and then
i have to terraform it and it's just
it's really gonna be bad so if you if
you're uh just
if you're a faint of heart just divert
your eyes because it's going to be
rough and tough there's gonna be so much
dense foliage in here no one's gonna
know what kind of
dinosaurs are hiding up in here and the
observation road is gonna be along a
coast because that sounds real cool
we've got so much money that it doesn't
even matter so we just take all this
money and we're gonna
we're gonna put it to some good use
we're gonna put it in some real good use
this is where the plateau is that's the
plateau
we're gonna build it right on the
there we go that's what i'm talking
about plateau is right there
cool all right cool we got that my path
is going to connect
with a nice curly boy right there
and then the path is going to wrap
around right there and then the
the whole enclosure is gonna be wrapping
around the whole ding-dong damn thing
there we go okay got it nailed it oh my
god
this is some cool [ __ ] i told you this
is going to be cool and
you know some of you didn't believe me
leave some work you might be interested
in
oh i might be interested in oh you know
you know i'm going to be interested in
that
i didn't make it electric fence because
frankly that would have taken too much
power and i just can't afford that
i am very very cheap i cannot afford
pretty much anything anymore
but what i can do now is i'm going to
make a nice
nice perilous mountain path that is
going to
skate right along the outskirts of what
we have
going on here all right and then that'll
be the end of the line
right there oh yeah and then we're gonna
have a bunch of observation decks
pretty much all over the place you think
you don't think all over the place
i'm thinking literally all over the
place okay we're gonna have one
here here cheer cheer
you know actually maybe we should have
one right
here and then that'll be the only one
right here yeah let's just do that one
let's let's do that one let's
let's not do that okay cool got it we've
got tons of observation decks
we got over a million still over a
million smackers we need more power out
of this so we're going to need another
substation
bought a bingo curvy boy okay cool then
we need power substations
cool then we need roads connecting all
these
yeah you are making the entertainment
division the crown
jewel of this entire operation
yeah i am yeah i am i am i am actually i
am
i am thank you for noticing thank you
for noticing all right we're gonna get
the live bait
we're gonna have two live bait two live
bait things we're gonna have two of them
and then we're gonna have two just
carnivore feeders
hey you know what what's wrong with live
bait right what's wrong
maybe we should get what's the
difference between these less efficient
it satisfies food
and provides activity for the hunter i
mean it seems like live bait would be
better right
wouldn't live bait be better overall i
think it would let's let's get another
one like in the
right here i think so anyway ah that was
all my money nah i forgot
they're so expensive i forgot how
expensive they were oh
no i have no money all right let's see
if we can get rid of this last one here
let's let's get rid of a refund no if it
was only a refund of 25 000
i wouldn't have done it i didn't mean to
do that
if it was only 20. i thought that was
my money and now i don't have one more
beat okay it's fine no
everybody you you seem worried about
it's nothing no it's nothing to worry
about
don't worry about there's nothing to
worry about i had a million dollars and
then i put it all in
bait i don't even have dinosaurs why did
i need bait
holy fine because these guys need water
that's one thing that they definitely
need there we go
that looks horrible
oh it looks horrible it looks so
horrible
oh god it looks is the worst thing i've
ever seen in my life
okay whatever it's fine that looks nice
i
kind of i guess oh boy what goat why are
you out
already giant water dick it is that
doesn't even look remotely
like a water dick in what world is that
a penis if what
is wrong with your penis if that's what
your penis looks like
i mean are you should you see a doctor
are you okay
all right we've got money we need to
make
the reaction speed what does it even do
oh it makes them grow
faster oh that's fascinating i would do
that
but i'm more worried about them being
successful
than anything such as that so what can
we afford what can we afford to make
we have a thing for rapid metabolism
uh ceratosaurus and that's pretty good
so let's get a rapid metabolism going on
the ceratosaurus
and then hopefully we'll be able to i'm
good i mean we're not gonna have bird
brain
i would like bird brain wait rapid oh i
don't even have rapid metabolism
well i gotta go research that first so
let's do that okay genetic research
rapid motable
i don't have that how do i get rapid
metabolism into him
that is a bird thing oh but i don't have
the science
hey doctor you want to give me a i've
received an
offer that will definitely help the
science division and can help
you as well you mean just keeping a
large number of guests in here is that
is that really all your so your plan
your master plan here
we're gonna get some ceratosaurs they
may not
have everything that we need but getting
one of those bad boys in here
that is going to be bananas
ooh two million
[Music]
two million that's a lot no well how do
i even know how many guests i have in
the park at any time
oh i'm close i'm not there yet but i am
close
i could probably get there if i get
another um i get another like hotel or
something but i don't want to spend
money on the hotel when i could get to
saratosa can i get another one do i have
enough money for another one i do
but i want to wait on it but i want to
get it now i'm going to get it now
okay so those are being built those will
give me more guests those will give me
more guests
oh oh i'm close to that too
oh i'll get a mission when i get a
mission i'll get a million dollars
hmm sabotage wait sabote
wait what wait
wait savage
they can sabotage me
why would they do that
why would they why why would they do
that
in what world why would they do that
what what benefit it's a dinosaur park
that's too dangerous
why would they why are they sad why why
why why okay all right oh big boy time
all right big boy time we're gonna
release this doo nu
oh yeah finally time for the big beastie
boy
oh yeah oh look at him
oh that's a big boy
you know you didn't have to prove
anything but the way you took
charge left an impression good work uh
this one
this one nice person to leg this job and
do it well
the security division is rewarding you
because on islam
you are clearly that person thank you i
think okay i'm going to call this one's
uh oh ho ho ho ho
well that fits into your name just right
this is cuddles he really likes to
cuddle you but he can't get you with his
arms
so he's gotta like he's gotta cuddle you
on his insides he's gonna
he gives you a big hug all the way
through his
body gives you a big old hug
a sniff snorf a snuff
all right this one's uh this one's
probably ready for a crunch and do but
this
this is this is snuggles
that's snuggles that's cuddles hey
but i put so much work into this one
failed enterprise save this island it's
like a challenge
and i mean who doesn't well i don't
but you this place sounds perfect for
you isla tacano
oh failed enterprise save this island
from financial ruin
demolish the failed infrastructure and
plan out your own path to success
world famous create star dinosaurs like
the tyrannosaurus rex to bring in record
guest numbers
gyro sears bring your guests closer to
the dinosaur with new visibility tools
like the gyrosphere
um i uh uh uh
uh i uh um but i just uh you know i
i just kind of like kind of like got
this one up and running i was uh really
interested
in snuggles and uh cuddles over here oh
here comes the crotching
here comes the crunch oh gonna give you
a nice cuddle
perfect oh not enough forest well sorry
that's not my fault that's your fault
that's your fault for not being in the
forest enough you got to give
people like a view so you know the
people need to be able to see
so i got that and this is looking good
so should i go over to the new island
humdiliham dooley ho ho i guess i could
just get like more research here
i kind of like you know would get
research
but then um monorail um
i don't know if i want that uh oh well
let's get out of this island we gotta go
let's
go how do we go how do we go to another
how do we get out here
can we go to another island how do we
get out of here uh
can i do
ah perfect okay
all right wait let me what was the um
wait what was the
what was the what was the special reward
because it said there was a special
reward for getting something done
here because it said there was like if
it said there was um
it said there was rewards like you could
get dig team bravo which i'm assuming
means another dig team if i get a
perfect five-star
island rating which would be nice but i
don't think i'm gonna get there
let's go over to the new place let's see
what's going on here let's see how
how bad available cash negative nine wow
whoo peebles wants a monorail ah
but i could build a monorail on i'll
aila takanyo and there's a disease here
i don't
i don't want that i'm gonna go to i'm
gonna go to island to kanyo
and build a monorail over there i'll
build a monorail i wanna go be in debt
that's what i know
that's what i love so i'm gonna go do
that oh
oh it's beautiful near here we're an
amusement park was built over the bones
of an abandoned one spared no expense
as hammond would say a biological
preserve
yeah you may have heard about it at
least the stuff that wasn't classified
oh this is one of your predecessors was
in charge of this island
it didn't go very well for them but
here's your opportunity to succeed where
they
failed you'll need to carefully consider
how to make money if you want to turn
this into a profitable endeavor
and you do trust me
okay oh this is the island this is the
the one from um this is the one from the
movie
this is the movie island it's already
got a monorail i'm telling you
it's pretty good i'm gonna demolish it
get some money
give me that money so that monorail is
gone we didn't need it anyway what a
bunch of garbage anyway am i right
people
i don't know what is this innovation
center
look personally i don't care how many
buildings we have
but i learned a long time ago that less
is never more
huh more is more so make more okay
uh okay all right um
cool well i mean that it's cool to have
an innovation center i guess but also we
have nomani
so i think i gotta get rid of yes
a million oh a milly milly i'm gonna get
a milli for me
okay this is good here though i like all
this this looks cool it's got a bunker
it's got whatever that is oh it's an
enclosure for
something and then uh yeah there's a
little dino area here just
for baby dinos which is probably what
we're gonna start with right
or maybe i should demolish these anyway
it looks like there's redundant here
i don't think we need all of it but i
kind of want all of it because that's
kind of cool and i want it and so i'm
keeping it
i'm keeping it and i want it and that's
all there is to it i'm gonna make this
area
bigger this is gonna be bigger yeah i
know path not connected but that's
because i'm gonna redo the path this
path was done stupidly
and it's for dumbs but i am not a dumb i
am smart and i am not
dumb so we're gonna make this real good
then
i will get a monorail i will i promise
oh
i'll get a monorail wink wonk i'll get
oh yeah you can count on me for a
monorail you know then
when i say i'm gonna get a monorail you
know i mean business
got it nailed it all right cool so that
is
leaves us with very little money [ __ ]
can i get a loan
can i get a loan can i get uh uh where
do i
oh yeah this needs to connect power okay
so that's connected we have
power i think this one needs a
substation
all right so we're 70 000 that's not
enough to get
literally anything arcade oh but i want
an arcade that sounds so cool
oh toy shop fast food the bar fossil
zone they sound so cool
don't sound so great those sound great
why can't i keep those
i'm losing money real fast okay we're
losing money what is
what is the problem here what's the
problem what's going on why is there a
red
something or other why why red what
what's the dealio what
what's the d what's the dealio are we
not open are we uh
what's the dealio what wha why are there
no people here there should be people
here i don't know why there's no people
here
probably because we got no dinos okay
we're gonna get rid of the fossil zone i
don't want to do that
oh god the bar no i can't drink anyway
so i guess it's okay all right we need
to make dinos
now now now we're gonna start off with
the cheapos
we're gonna start off with the cheapos
we're gonna modify the [ __ ] out of them
they're gonna be so modified so we're
gonna get a couple of these boys
and then suddenly baby we got a stew
going
i think we just did this by the skin of
our titty tit tits
okay we need to feed them
ah feed them i did not
think about feeding them probably fine
okay get out there all right meemo mommo
mommo mimi mama mama
probably it's probably fine i'm not
worried about it okay go go go we gotta
go
we gotta go come on we gotta make more
gotta make more get out there
entertain people just get out there we
gotta get people in
we gotta get people oh yeah here they
come oh they're ready
oh you're ready why is this still a
problem what is the problem
what is why is something a problem here
we got two dinos which means that
the game is on
any minute now people are gonna come
flooding through those doors
oh people are flooding through those
doors oh give me give me give me
contracts give me no
give give me contracts i need contracts
like right now ooh
an archaeonormothelusis
reaction speed do i even have reaction
speed an archaeothermis i don't i can't
even research reaction speed because i
don't have that
maybe i gotta go to another park to be
able to research
that makes a lot of sense do they can
make money when i'm not there that would
be pretty cool
that'd be pretty pretty tight they might
not do that they might absolutely not do
that
problem also i don't even know if i have
the ability to get an archaeon
themimimus nithimimus ooh
there's the people there's the people oh
look at my i
i've got a five out of five facility
rating
oh yeah
[Laughter]
but these guys these guys don't do [ __ ]
for me so i got to get a big
i got to get a big i can't afford any
big
nap i can't afford any big okay i think
that's i think that's
pretty much everything there is to it
and i still don't know why this is here
feeders
ah yeah afford to i'd can i afford a yes
i can okay
i can afford one feedy there we go i
have no ranger station but i've got one
feedy boy
okay that is gonna do it for now
let's save this as one feedy boy
that is all the time i have for
this game thank you guys so much for
watching have a good night
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you